Hello everybody!
Sorry, I was trying to find my scene.
Wait, what's happening?
Oh, sorry, we're live.
I didn't give you the countdown like I usually do.
You were just talking about your pizza.
I was like, oh yeah, sorry, let me find my scene.
I was like, hello!
I stopped mid-conversation to swap my scene.
Wait, why are my ears messed up on your screen?
What?
Is it?
Was it not supposed to look like that?
No!
Hold on, I'll show you how they look on mine.
Maybe I won't match you then.
Wait, that's not fair.
I don't want to mess up with my cat ears.
I'm still a kitty.
Still a kitty and...
Mid-kitty.
I was going to say, kint.
No, that's gross!
Mine's a little low.
Don't worry, I'll turn her up.
Oh yeah, you were at like 200.
Wait, what the heck?
Okay, why is your...
I don't know!
Turn it off.
Take it off.
Take what off?
The white thing off.
The ghost thing.
I can't.
That's my ghost thing.
It's okay.
It already looks like that.
What?
Okay, wait.
Yeah?
Oh, no.
I don't have automatic gain control on.
I don't know.
Wait.
Maybe I shouldn't have it on.
Hello?
Okay, I'm going to turn this off so I can like...
See, I can take your ghost thingy off on my end.
What are you talking about?
Oh, I can take it off.
Oh, now I'm loud.
Oh, now I took it off.
Okay.
Wait, why do you have that on?
How do you...
Why do you have that little hat on?
What are you talking about?
The little hat.
Are you already drunk?
No, I'm not.
I will be very soon.
No, like your little hat.
I don't have a hat.
Yeah, you have the hat.
Like, on my screen.
Yeah, I don't want that.
Well, no, I have to have that.
I can't.
Take it off.
Just pretend.
Like, just take it off.
Like, and then it will register.
Hold on.
I'm going to redo my ears.
But on your screen.
Wait, did they disappear?
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, they got it.
Cat ear.
Just take it.
No, it's the hat thing you're wearing.
My hat?
That's not a hat.
What is that?
Wait, what is that?
Is that not a hat?
It's like a little cloth.
Yeah, it's a hat.
I use it in case I forget, like, underwear or something.
No, it's still there.
The hat's still there.
Okay.
Wait, oh my gosh, it's behind me.
This sucks.
It's like surgically implanted on your head.
Wait, no, put it in front.
I am on my screen.
Just force it.
Until it's, like, in the front.
Hold on, I'm going to try again.
Force it.
Just force it there.
Yeah, just force it.
Hold on.
Wait, maybe I can do this.
Okay.
Get Celia here and, like, have...
Just remove...
I know, Celia!
Celia, can you remove the hat for me?
Oh, I got it to work!
Yay!
Okay, I have one ear.
Celia, we need you to do a quick, like, ten minute change for us.
It's my ghost thing.
What?
Okay, I'm watching.
Why don't we just take up the majority of the screen?
There we go.
This is the... this is massage now.
This is...
No, I'm self-conscious.
Don't take up the screen while I'm fixing my ear.
Alright.
Okay, so one minute I was talking about...
We were talking about a lot of stuff.
But one of the things we were talking about while I was setting up...
Sorry for being late, but...
You're not sorry.
I'm sorry.
Like, dragoons and the wisps gave up their time to watch you babysit me.
Apparently, I'm peaking, by the way.
Oh, you're peaking?
Okay, I'll turn you...
I'll turn you down a little bit.
Okay, say something.
Is it better now, guys?
I don't know.
I think I fixed my audio, so...
Okay, so basically, what we're...
One of the things, we were talking about cold pizza.
Because...
You know, I got my...
It just hits different.
I just got my alcohol, and I was like, okay, I should...
I should eat...
Like, put something in my stomach right now.
Because you don't want to drink on an empty stomach, or it's going to hit harder.
Anyway, so...
Obviously, I had the cold pizza, because I got depressed over Marvel Rivals.
Well...
Oh, sad.
It's such a sad story.
I was telling Min about how sad it was.
And I was like, because I hate myself, let me eat my...
The pizza I ordered last night for my depression grind.
Yeah.
And then, apparently, like...
Min was like, oh, I love cold pizza.
It just hits different.
But like, I was just like...
It hits different.
I was like, yeah, but like...
Hot pizza is just objectively better.
It's just...
It's just better than cold pizza, because like, you know...
Cold pizza is literally a depression meal, and that's what I have right now.
Because I...
Not only did I have...
Did I not get top 500...
Okay, your chat is saying cold pizza good.
It do hit different.
Okay, okay.
People who say it do hit different.
Are you American?
Also, are you...
Are you Asian or not?
Are you Asian?
It does hit different, though.
Yes, I'm American.
I like hot food.
Cold pizza is better.
No, it's not.
Like, you get the cheese pull...
I'm reading your chat.
If you warm it up, you get the cheese pull.
And then, like, it's extra cheesy and stuff.
But it's a different experience.
It's just like...
You had a really rough day.
And you're just...
Nothing in life matters anymore.
Not even...
So, why should I waste my time warming up food?
It's just...
It's just more sad.
You just don't understand...
You just don't get it.
You just...
No, I get the depression meal.
Because that's what...
That's why I literally just had cold pizza.
No, I get it.
Not only did I...
Did I not climb in Marble Rivals Rank...
After the last 2-3 days of playing that fucking game.
But also...
What did you end at?
I went down.
And then...
Okay, so I had, like, 4 hours of sleep, by the way.
Because I was like...
Okay, I either play for 4-5 hours...
See if I could make it.
And then...
And if I don't make it, I might have to try and play more while drunk.
And then I was like...
I shouldn't.
While drunk?
You think that you would do better?
No.
That's why I was like...
I am not sobering up enough to, like...
Because, like, it ends at midnight.
Like, the time.
It ends at exactly midnight.
And I was like...
There is no way I'm gonna be...
Sober up...
She wanted to play a horror game instead.
She wanted to be like...
And...
No, the thing is...
I was like...
Either today, I'm drinking to celebrate...
Or I'm drinking...
Or I'm drinking because something bad happened.
Yeah.
Now...
Drink the depression and pain away.
You'll have a massage to...
No, the massage will make you forget all about it.
It will scare away your worries.
Exactly.
It will scare it away.
Yeah.
Yeah, see, it works now.
I'm gonna have Kat here's next outfit.
Oh, really?
Leaks?
Do you wanna see?
Yeah, oh my gosh, yeah.
I'm gonna see it.
You won't, guys.
Yeah, you won't, guys.
Alright.
I'll show you my new outfit.
I don't know if I showed you.
Oh, I wanna see.
Alright, yeah, yeah.
Let me show you.
Okay, we'll send.
Don't worry, you'll hear our reactions to each other's new outfits.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's just as good, right, guys?
I'm sending this to the right person, right?
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, let me see.
Alright.
Oh my god!
You are so playing it up.
No, it's because of the second one.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god!
I can see a lot of fanart because of that one thing over...
Right!
This is not fair.
Life's not fair.
Wait, what's yours?
I didn't get top 500.
Life's not fucking fair.
Why is everyone spamming that, like, ugly angry?
Now you know how I felt.
You know how many hours I played Rivals in the last three days?
I've invested at least ten hours a day the last three...
Life's not fucking fair.
So let me have this.
Wait, send me yours.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, I love the hair.
Extra freaky.
You heard it here first, folks.
She has, like, the cycle of abuse continues.
That's right!
Okay, I can say something really fucked up.
I had a bad day at work and I'm the dad that came back drinking.
Wait, what?
I came back.
I'm the father figure right now.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Aw, man.
Okay, I'm trying to find the PNGs right now.
You know how, like, I download everything in the downloads folder?
Oh, me too.
Yeah, I'm like, there's so many images of other stuff.
I only had this so easily because I got it today.
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, okay, let me... I'll show you two outfits.
They know there's two outfits coming in.
They know.
Okay, so...
What?
Mom, did you have two outfits?
Yeah.
Alright.
And then...
Oh my god!
Wait, that's so cute!
Wait,
I have another version of that, though, that's even sillier.
Oh, I like it.
Okay, but, like...
Let's see, where's the other one?
I'm trying to find the other one.
Yeah, react to what you like about it, but, like, vaguely.
We're matching again.
Look at the hair, we're matching again.
Oh, wait, really?
That's funny.
Guys, it was... Like, it's really unintentional, guys.
It's so unintentional.
We literally just saw this today.
It's so funny.
Oh my god.
Here's the other one that's coming out first, though.
Here's the other one.
Oh, coming out first, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
What are those?
Oh yeah, there's physics on that.
Wait, wait, I'll show you what...
I'll show you what Celia sent me.
It's like...
It's kind of disgusting.
Okay, but, like, it's actually so fucking funny.
They're all angry.
It's like, that's not fair!
Wait, this is... You said you were the dad.
This is, like, the most dad.
The most dad.
I hate that.
What do you mean, ew?
What do you mean, not ew?
What?
It's so cute.
It's like a cow udder.
Also, like, that...
The first one I sent you, it actually has, like, an alternate...
An alternate outfit to it.
Wait, let me see if I can find...
I don't know if I...
Let me see if I can find it.
I know I sent her, like...
Oh, here.
Here's the udder...
The udder outfit.
Oh my god, udder.
That's literally what you can call this one.
You guys...
You guys will understand.
Look at the...
Oh, cute!
Look at the jacket.
Yeah, I like...
I like the one you went with, though.
Yeah.
The main one.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, you're getting both?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm getting both so it can swap between the two.
Like, how I feel that day.
That's cute.
Yeah.
Okay, guys.
If you can't show it, sorry.
Sorry, guys.
Sorry.
Sorry, we can't show it to you.
Oh, you know we really want to, though, Wisps and Dragoons.
You know that.
Yeah.
We really, really want to.
But, like...
Yeah, but we just, you know...
You know...
It's gotta be complete.
We'll show you when it's at its ultimate best form.
Yeah, and like, you know, it's to build up hype.
Now you're so excited now, right?
To see what you can possibly...
You're like, what's this disgusting udder?
What is that freaky hairstyle she's talking about?
What could make it so freaky?
Oh, man.
I'm not looking forward to playing this game.
Wait, have you ever played?
You chose this.
I've never played this.
You've never played Visage?
Never?
Like, you heard about it, though, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I've never played it.
Yeah, everyone knows it's apparently the scariest game anyone's ever played.
Yeah, but you played P.T., though.
You played P.T.
I know, I was gonna say.
Yeah, like, this game was inspired by P.T., that's the thing.
They have a section in there that has actual, like...
What was it called?
Like, tribute or Easter egg to it.
That's inspired by P.T.
And, like, what it could have been and stuff like that.
So there's, like, bits and pieces of it.
Like, a whole homage to it.
Yeah.
But it's, like, one of the chapters.
And we're not doing that chapter.
Oh, what?
How far do you wanna get today?
I don't ask.
I don't know.
Honestly, wherever this bottle's gonna take me.
You could get through the whole thing if the bottle helped.
No.
It is a long game, man.
Someone said, charity goal says all chapters.
Did it actually say all chapters?
Oh, my God.
I don't even remember what I wrote.
It's been a year.
Yes, it did.
You said all chapters.
Yeah, all chapters.
Who's a charity right now?
I am.
You're my charity case, cuz I'm here.
We're not gonna make any progress today.
Even your mod said, yes, it's all chapters.
Alright, let's do this.
It's like a year-long event.
For charity!
Every couple months, I hit you up and it's like, alright, you wanna do part two?
Every part, it's gonna be, like, two to three months later.
I was like, alright, I'm ready for part two.
And I hit you up in, like, June or some shit.
Sorry, I can't do that.
You'll just have to play by yourself, Doki.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
I'm busy that day.
On the exact all days of June.
Yeah, actually.
What about July then, huh?
Let's just schedule it in advance right now for part two.
Next week.
Okay, wouldn't it be better to just get through it?
So if you space it out...
Yeah, but then I'll forget about what happened last time.
And then you're like, oh wait, you're right.
You'll grow a mute to it.
I'll grow, like, accustomed to the game.
Scared every time.
Just re-engaging with it.
Alright, I guess we'll do next week.
Oh, I'm busy next week?
Oh, yeah, okay, how about in two weeks then?
Okay.
Oh, is that easy?
Guys, she's easy.
What?
Okay, no, I'm busy the rest of the year.
Okay, 2026.
The anniversary.
You play it once a year.
What if I just play it once a year?
Every anniversary, we go do another part of Massage.
I feel like we'd actually do that, though.
Just to fuck with them.
Just to be like...
Happy anniversary, guys.
Massage Part 2.
Part 2!
You wanna start up the game now?
Alright, let me...
Guys, I actually downloaded a game, like, the day I joined the call.
Like, today.
Oh, yeah, she called me and was like, I'm installing the game right now.
Yeah, I was like, sorry, if I'm, like, buffering right now, I'm actually installing the game.
I don't know if we're big enough.
Are we big enough on this?
I feel like if I say that, they're like, no, we want you bigger.
I'll pick it a little bigger.
No, I think that's good.
Yeah.
Okay, let me... I'll make it a little tiny bit bigger.
There you go.
You're so tiny.
Look how short you are.
You literally are, like, not even that taller than me.
That is not true.
That is true!
I look down.
I remember looking down.
You are, like, what?
152?
That's, like, two centimeters taller than me.
Oh, yeah, no, guys, no, she's lying.
Why would I lie?
Is that including your cat ears as well?
Are you including... are you including your little... what is it called?
The... I'm scared of pronouncing it.
Oh, yeah.
I'm scared of pronouncing it wrong because I always pronounce it the other... the other one.
Say it.
Say the other one.
No, no, no, no, no.
Say it.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Alright.
Okay, I'm... I'm not ready.
I'm not actually ready, but I'm ready.
You are.
Okay.
Alright.
So, I told Mint that I tried to play this last time a couple of years ago.
And it didn't... I don't even know if it's... if it has my old save file.
But I tried to play this a couple of years ago, also drunk, by the way.
And I told you guys that, too.
Where I played... and then, like, I only got to the level select.
Because, like, I was... it was just so fucking scary that I could never make it past the level select.
Wait, so you never actually started the game?
No, and then I watched someone else play one of the chapters.
And then... and then I, like, YouTubed, like, a no commentary playthrough of one of the chapters.
And we just pretend I played it while I was drunk.
I was roleplaying.
You just pretended to play.
Yeah, yeah.
I was like, woah, guys.
Well, luckily, this time is for charity, so you can't do that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, let me...
Okay, let me boot up.
Alright.
Visage.
Also, how's Mint's...
oh.
Yeah, I was gonna say you.
Tiny... okay.
Teensy tiny bit.
Okay.
Teensy tiny.
Are you gonna screen share the game to me?
Yeah.
No, I'm just like, you're just listening to the...
I watch through the YouTube.
Yeah, you're just gonna watch through the YouTube stream so it's always, like, delayed.
Okay.
Yeah, I got the stream.
Alright.
Oh, look, it's you, Doki Bird!
Oh my god, that's me.
Someone please free me.
It's you!
Let's see.
Let's look at the audio.
Okay, so, like, I learned this from the first time I played it.
And there's no, like, when you pause the game, it's like, you have to press an extra button to pause the game.
It's that fucked up.
What?
It's not like...
Yeah, so, like, when it's paused, it's not actually paused.
Oh, okay.
So, like, okay, we're doing new game.
Alright, Visage is hard.
Oh, yeah, there's a lot of puzzles too, so that's what you're gonna be helping me with that.
That's what I'm here for.
That's the, yeah, you're the puzzle master.
Visage.
Oh, it looks like Silent Hill The Room.
Oh, I think I upped the brightness all the way up too from the first time.
It looks really... yeah, that's like...
Yeah, I was like...
I'm pretty sure I upped the brightness all the way up from the first time.
Okay.
Whoa, yeah, there's, like, there's a chapter where there's, like, a baby crying and shit like that.
Oh, it's so PT.
Yeah, but, yeah, I remember it, and that's the chapter we're not doing today.
Okay.
Wait, how do you know all the chapters then if you've never played it?
Oh, no, I read, like, it's the scare, it's the one that's, like, the PT inspired one.
Oh.
Yeah, so I know about...
A muffled cry is you.
Wait, they have no game audio.
No, there is, it's just really quiet.
There's, like...
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Wait, actually, I'll turn it up just in case.
It's just really quiet because nothing's actually happening.
Yeah, and all you hear is the bullets.
Yeah.
Oh.
I don't really remember the beginning.
I guess he's gonna kill his family.
Oh, probably.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Do you think she's okay?
Her dogs are out.
Maybe it's just roleplay.
Yeah.
Totally.
Yeah, it's just roleplay.
This whole game is just a whole, like, home invasion roleplay.
Like BDSM roleplay.
POV.
Some couples are into that, everybody.
Yeah, like the freaky shit.
It's like, remember...
The key's under the doormat, honey.
Oh, there's the whole family.
Wait, you shouldn't get the kids involved.
Yeah, they should stay in the bedroom, guys.
Yeah.
It is a freaky couple.
Oh!
Oh.
Why is, like, the blood out of focus?
Yeah.
Like, it's in focus.
The blood is the one that's in focus right now.
Oh, no, that's the child.
Oh, my God!
Oh.
Guys, it's okay.
It's part of the roleplay.
They have blood bags.
They have blood bags and everything, guys.
It's like a ketchup bag.
Oh, goodbye.
That was a child.
Jesus.
Boss, you just killed a child.
That's why you're the best.
It's like a Metal Gear meme.
Yeah.
Boss, you just killed a child.
Amazing work.
That's why you're the best.
A real soldier right there.
Alright.
I'm walking out.
Ew.
You're hobbling out.
You're not walking.
Oh, welcome to PT.
Yippee.
Okay, so, when I first played this game...
I didn't realize, when you're there, it's the level select.
So, I was stuck there for, like, an hour.
Because I did not know where to go.
And I was so fucking scared.
Oh, yeah.
Gamma...
Wait.
That's not normal, right?
The bottom side is supposed to be invisible.
I was like...
Oh, yeah.
That's definitely, like, past Derky's save file right there.
128720.
Oh, your texture qualities are low.
Change everything to high.
It's because if I can't see what's going on...
If I...
If I don't know what's going...
This is 2025, Doki.
This is...
For charity.
If I can't see the ghost, then everything will be fine.
Turn down the gamma.
The pixels will become less scary.
I thought they looked really ugly.
I was like, this is...
Wow, it's really old.
It looks so terrible.
Wait, is the resolution scale supposed to be high as well?
I don't know what the resolution scale is.
I don't know, actually.
Turn it down for charity.
Oh my god, it's scary.
Look how scary it is.
Like, I can see...
I can see everything when the camera's up.
And then I can't see anything now.
Look at that.
Look how dark it is.
It is pretty dark.
Yeah.
I would put it halfway.
Put it halfway between the middle and...
Okay, here.
Yeah, like that.
Yeah, yeah.
And now I can vaguely see what's going on there.
Okay.
Yeah.
So you can see that it's still playing.
You can see the light is still going on and off.
So you're in this part of the setting.
It's not even...
You have to pause the game.
You have to go to...
Wait, where do you have to go?
Oh, you have to go pause game.
What?
You have to click this to pause the game.
The game will pause?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
That's so messed up.
Yeah.
So you're just like...
You know, if a ghost comes out, you're like...
You have to press this too.
And then it gives a countdown.
So what if a ghost is on your ass?
It gets you.
I'm gonna get you.
It has a delay.
That's messed up.
Alright, let me turn this down too.
Alright.
Okay, so I was stuck here for...
Oh, wait.
What's this?
I gotta go to the bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back.
Wait, what?
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna wait here real quick.
Oh, progress.
Oh my god.
I literally just got goosebumps just by looking at the progress room.
Mint's mic is peaking.
Don't wait for me.
Okay, your mic is peaking sometimes, by the way.
You might have to adjust it.
Like, turn it down a little.
Okay, she didn't hear.
The hub contains items that represent your progress throughout the game.
These items are collected in different ways, including the end of a chapter.
Once collected, the items will automatically appear in the progress room.
Okay.
Alright.
Can I open this?
Is there anything there?
Oh.
Oh, is this a confessional?
Forgive me, Father, for I have sinned.
Okay, now I don't like that.
Okay, let me up my sensitivity a little bit more.
I don't like this.
What do you mean a wink?
Mint, they just literally said you winked at the chat.
I know you're there, right?
Oh.
Okay.
Hello?
Hello, hello?
Oh, I have a neighbor?
Oh, game volume's low?
Okay, don't worry.
I'll fix that.
Whoa.
Sorry to blow my nose.
Don't want to mute myself right now.
I'm at that point of stage in my life where I don't care anymore.
Alright.
Hey, welcome back.
Goddammit, how did you know?
Welcome back.
Oh my god, you just started moving and everything.
Okay, so I didn't realize...
I thought you were paying attention to the game, you know?
I have OBS on my second monitor.
Like, I can see you move in my peripheral vision.
Okay, pay attention to the game.
What's going on?
What's happening?
I just got a phone call from my neighbor and she was like, are you okay?
And then I'm like, oh look, that is me.
Look at all the alcohol I drank today.
Wait, have you taken any sips yet?
Oh.
I've been drinking since like the beginning of this stream.
Okay.
So I didn't realize this was the level select, so I was like really freaked out.
And like, I was walking around and just being like...
You know, I was like, oh my god, a ghost is going to appear down this hallway.
Like a star there.
Wait, so this is a level select?
Yeah, this is literally a level select.
Oh, it's not like the actual game?
No, it's not the actual game.
And that like...
Like, that freaked me out for the longest time because like...
What was that sound?
Don't say that.
You didn't hear that though?
The game turned down low.
That's why your chat keeps going, hey, it's low Doki.
And then look at where the master volume is.
Past Doki knows what's up.
Okay.
Oh.
Have you gotten this far before?
Yeah, I got to where I picked up an item and then started a chapter and then I stopped playing.
You piked up an item?
I'm not okay.
Your character's sanity will affect your gameplay.
Standing too long in the dark will decrease your character's sanity amongst various other elements.
Okay, so I...
Basically, when my sanity gets lower, there's more like paranormal activities that goes on.
You're in the dark right now.
Yeah, but I'm in the character select.
Okay.
Oh my God, even the light thing.
I don't think it would be telling you that unless it mattered right now.
Oh my God.
I hate this.
Even like the click clack is like so loud.
Oh, yeah, you're...
I don't know if they...
Guys, did her mic peaking thing fixed itself yet or not?
Handles...
Am I still peaking?
Yeah, she's still peaking, guys.
Sanity events occur randomly throughout the game.
Oh my God.
Yeah, you're still peaking.
Yeah, I could hear the peaking.
You gotta fix that part.
Let me look at my mic too.
No, my mic's fine.
My mic's always fine.
Okay.
Peek-a-boo.
What's that?
Oh, it's the radio.
This is so PT.
Yeah, I know that's...
Yeah, be prepared to broken lights.
Okay.
I don't think this is level select.
I think this is the tutorial.
It's tutorial slash level select.
How do I put the...
Can I fix it?
Yay!
Alright, I replaced the light bulb.
Why can't I just leave?
Yeah, I know, right?
Oh, it's jammed.
Get a hammer.
It's jammed.
Can I just get a hammer and just smash that and just leave?
I prefer when it's peanut buttered.
Okay, so UCC, this is one of the levels.
This is the other one.
There's one upstairs, but that's not the one we're getting.
What was that?
Stop, stop.
Stop.
Oh, there's like footsteps behind you.
Like there's double footsteps.
Okay, there's meds here.
Okay.
Pills acts as an aid for your character's sanity.
Oh, you need that.
Yeah, I need to take my meds right now.
Alright.
I didn't read it properly.
How do I put it in my inventory?
Oh.
I don't know.
Guys, I didn't read it properly.
What do I... How do I...
Stop.
Did you hear that?
Pills here.
What if I swear I'm actually gonna take the pills?
Oh, it's swinging.
Oh my god.
That's a ghost.
Candles can be placed here.
Oh, something's gonna come out of that.
Oh.
Oh, I should never turn that off.
Oh, they have so much toilet paper.
Oh my god.
They have toilet paper in here.
And pasta dental.
Pasta dental?
Okay.
That looks like...
It's like a tomato paste.
Yeah.
What's this?
Oh, ibuprofen.
I need that.
Let's take ibuprofen together.
You...
What if we just, you know, take some ibuprofen together in the bathroom?
Oh, they have that...
There's cough syrup.
Yeah, there's cough syrup.
And there's like...
What's it called?
The pink juice?
The pink...
Oh, the Pepto-Bismol.
Yeah, Pepto-Bismol.
The pink juice.
I don't think it's...
No!
I took my meds!
No, I'm straight up!
No, don't take it off!
No!
I am very...
Okay, I need...
Okay, let's see.
Switch hands...
Hold...
Drop...
Use...
How do I...
Okay.
Now, it's on my right hand.
No, I took my meds.
What if you, like, scroll wheel?
Does that do anything?
No, no, no.
Wait, it's like...
Okay, switch hands...
Crouch...
Run...
Quick save.
Okay.
Hold...
Use...
Zoom...
No, I can't do anything.
I can't do anything.
Okay.
Click on the spot in the inventory?
Oh, I did it.
I did that.
What was that?
Stop.
It's not me!
It's the game!
Oh my...
It's playing!
Which level are we doing?
I'm gonna turn that radio off.
That's annoying.
Yeah.
Okay, so we got the key.
Which is the first level?
Okay, we're not doing that.
We have the key.
Wait, why are we not doing that?
There's only two levels in this game, and...
There's only...
It's this level...
That's not...
You literally said there was one upstairs!
I think we should ask...
The Dragoons who donated their hard-earned money for charity.
Which level they would like you to do.
If you donate...
Post your receipts right now.
Post it under Doki's hashtag.
I will literally fact-check.
And I will be like...
This person said...
This one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then it's...
Hold on, I'm going to your Twitter.
Are you like...
Registered?
Do you have your voter ID with you too?
Post it under hashtag...
Doki Bird or Birdseeders.
I will check.
Yeah, Birdseeders.
Do you please post your receipt...
Of the money you donated to the charity.
And then what you're...
What chapter you would like me to do.
Yeah.
And I'll...
We'll do it.
We'll fact-check you.
But you have to...
Okay, but also...
Don't dox yourself.
You can...
You can censor...
Just censor any important information in there.
And then like...
But you have only 5 minutes to post.
Mint, do you want my SSN too?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, if you're so willing.
So then you get to pick.
And then we'll have a...
We'll count the votes.
And...
And make sure that everyone is properly registered.
Wait a second.
I'm just gonna go with like the first one we see.
Because...
I mean, you have to do all of them anyway.
Exactly.
SSN address.
The bank account.
Your maiden's name.
Your mom's maiden's name.
The name of your first pet and everything.
Alright.
Oh, where you went to school.
Your first...
The name of your first school.
Your favorite car.
Your favorite teacher.
Your blood type.
I don't even know my blood type.
Just to be safe.
If you're like...
If you're properly registered in the...
In the...
The ToeKeeper elections.
We'll also need your birth certificate too.
Just to be sure.
Birth certificate.
Your birth certificate.
House deed.
Yeah, yeah.
The deed of your house.
And if you're in debt or not.
I keep hearing footsteps behind you.
I know.
If I don't look back, I'll never see them.
Oh, and then if you're an organ donor.
That's the most important part.
I'm not seeing anyone vote.
Oh, wait.
Latest.
Oh!
Let's see.
Um, okay.
We have a couple.
We have a couple?
Already?
I said...
Okay, wait.
I need to see this now.
What do you mean by a couple?
Uh, Noxten.
Noxten.
Okay, no, I didn't...
Let me...
Let me check, uh...
Uh...
Said, do the second level first.
Reminder that she has to do every chapter for the 90K characters.
What the heck is the second level?
What is considered a second level?
Yeah, which one is that?
I'll look it up.
I got you.
Visage levels.
Okay.
Dolores' chapter?
There's only four, Doki.
Okay, that is four too many.
Like, that's three too many already.
Um, okay, but like...
But like...
Uh...
Oh, we looked at the first one, right?
The game isn't paused.
Alright.
No, okay.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
No, it is.
It is.
I tapped out.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Thank God.
Okay, I tapped out.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, we're doing the first...
Guys, guys, we're doing the first one.
We're doing the, um, the first person that posted.
So, oh, I'm so sorry, FaintSmile.
You were just a minute too late.
I guess we're just gonna do the second level first.
Oh, no, but FaintSmile did it more.
No, no, no.
You did say...
No, no.
No, I think that the higher amount should get priority.
Oh, you're making amendments to the clauses now.
And you know, amendments need to be voted by the full party.
The upstairs level seems very sought after.
That could be the second level, who knows?
What do you mean very sought...
It's one guy.
It's one to one.
No, no, no.
I'm sure, I'm sure Noxton meant the second level.
Oh, so like, Noxton's opinion doesn't matter.
That's what you're trying to say.
No, I'm saying what...
Are you trying to say that?
Translating what Noxton meant.
He said second level is Dolores's chapter.
No, that's just...
I actually...
Sorry, that was...
Hold on.
Oh, and then...
That was GameRant.com and they're always wrong, so...
So don't...
GameRant.com Okay.
Oh, Cody just said the...
Said the what?
What?
Oh.
Wait.
Oh, what happened?
He said...
What?
What happened?
The screen share disappeared.
Oh, the screen...
Oh, no, it's back.
Sorry.
Hi, Noxton Amtet here.
I thought it was you, Anton.
Oh my gosh.
Upstairs sounds like cooler content.
Do that for charity.
I'll see.
Okay, I'll do...
Okay, look.
Now you're just getting peer pressured by Mint, guys.
Now you're just getting peer pressured by her, but like...
You should have never...
Doki, you did the first thing that you should never do.
You showed weakness.
The first level.
And you said which chapter was the worst.
First level.
So I guess we're gonna do the second chapter, guys, which is...
Wait, is it this one?
Check the hashtag.
I'm checking.
Oh.
Is it this one?
Nexi also said...
Oh, Nexi.
Holy...
What?
Oh my God.
Wait, what?
What?
The amount that Nexi donated.
Holy hell.
They also said...
Okay, but did they put their birth certificate?
Did they...
Are they registered to vote for her?
Alright, time to go upstairs.
Time to go upstairs.
Everyone's so generous.
Thank you guys for donating all that time ago.
Yeah, thank you.
But like...
Yep, keep going.
Okay, time to go.
But like, there's some...
Wait, can you reshare...
Rescreen share?
Oh, is it?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Did it not work?
Okay, oh my God.
I just hear them go...
What are you talking about?
It's like in the screen share.
It's just...
It's still not sharing.
Hold on, I'm gonna leave.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, it turned on by itself.
Okay, I'm back.
Okay, do you see it?
Yeah, it sounds like an ice cream truck.
Oh my God.
Okay, so this is the...
This is the upstairs level.
No, it's not!
Go upstairs.
What?
Is this it?
No, it's not.
I'm trying to remember where it is.
Oh, candles can be placed.
You've been in the dark for a while.
Oh, nice!
What's this?
Can you tie him in a knot?
Can you tie him in a bow?
It's the panda drawing.
Oh, the panda?
Okay.
Let's go!
Oh, pandas are cute!
It's the panda drawing.
What's so scary about this one?
It's the PT one.
Oh, this whole game feels pretty PT already.
Oh my God, why is the child sick?
What the hell is that?
Oh yeah, it's telling you to not be in the dark or something.
No!
Come on, Noki!
Okay, let me just...
This house is huge.
This is still just a kid level select.
This is why I didn't get past the level select.
Oh my God.
But you already watched someone play it, so you'll know everything already.
I don't remember.
I was drunk and it was years ago.
Let me take a sip real fast.
Oh, they're telling me to make me even quieter.
Okay, yeah, I can turn you down right now.
Let me...
Where's your face?
There you go.
Okay.
I don't know.
What do you have me at?
I have you at 174 and 10.9.
Oh, I think you can put me down to like 100.
Oh, really?
Okay.
Oh, did you fix your mic thing?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why did it turn off?
Oh, I don't know.
Oh my God, why did...
Okay, I need to pause the game.
It like literally turned off the lights by itself.
I think you did that.
Okay.
Alright, is her volume...
Is her volume better now, guys?
Hey, guys.
Oh, you're trying to say they can't hear anything.
It's because I paused the game.
What do you mean?
The game volume is low.
Okay.
Option audio.
Is she okay now, guys?
Is her mic volume okay now?
I think so.
I said much better.
I saw people.
Alright.
Okay.
There's nothing happening.
You can't hear anything because...
Okay, taking this item will begin a chapter.
There are two types of key items.
Cement.
They are usually discernible key items.
Is that why you didn't want to go to this one?
It's the cement.
It's the cement level.
Okay.
You found the drawing of the panda.
What's gonna happen?
Oh, Lucy!
Lucy's chapter.
Who's Lucy?
Lucy!
I hate this.
Turn the light on.
You know something.
No, I turned on this light.
Little baby.
Oh, you can... Wait, can you hide in there?
No.
There's no hiding from this.
How are you supposed to...
What's that sound?
Did you hear that?
Oh, that just opened.
Knock, knock.
I think you need to knock back.
Hello?
Okay, give me...
Wait a second.
I need to wait for the alcohol to hit.
We just started!
Okay.
Who's a brave kitty cat?
Not me.
Meow.
Four, three, just...
Doki kept just going, meow.
Meow.
I was so convincing.
Oh my god, my dog is like, who's that?
Oh, he was convinced it was a cat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Meow.
Dad doesn't like meow.
Okay, he's never seen a cat before, so...
What?
Yeah, yeah, I don't know how he's gonna react.
I don't know what that is.
He's like, what is this creature you speak of?
Okay, okay.
Hopefully...
Oh my gosh, have you ever played Lifeline?
Lifeline?
No, what's that?
It's a voice controlled, like, RPG.
Oh.
You should play it.
Oh, really?
Is it scary?
No, it's actually not scary.
Oh, wait, how does, like, what's the, like, premise of the game?
Uh, you're on, like, this space station and aliens invade.
So I was blowing my nose.
Yeah, it's sci-fi.
And then you control the lady to fight and stuff.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, it's really fun.
It sounds interesting.
You should play it, yeah.
Okay, the way, the more you talk about it, the more I'm, like, less convinced that it's, like, a scary game.
It's not scary, it's not.
Okay.
I mean, there's some scary parts of it, but...
Oh, you have to scream at what?
Yeah, you have to yell at the lady.
Okay, wait.
I think he's actually hungry.
I'll be right back real quick.
What?
I'm not stalling!
My dog needs food!
Uh, why did you feed him earlier?
Guys, I'm gonna have her play Lifeline.
The dog made me think of it, because I think of Rio.
The girl's name is Rio, and she goes, little bark, or big bark.
That's what made me think of it.
But we're gonna have her play, and she's gonna lose her mind, too.
I'm back.
Alright.
Welcome back.
Okay.
This is gonna be a long couple of months of this game.
Months?!
I don't think we're gonna make it a lot, but I think it's gonna take us a couple of playthroughs to finish the first chapter.
I believe.
Come on, guys!
Oh.
You scared me.
Everything looks the same.
You turned around so fast.
God, I hate this child.
Can you die in this game?
Yes.
That was a quick save.
Where do I go?
Was that her down there at the end of the hall?
Shut up.
Shut the fuck up right now.
I was just asking.
Can't ask questions anymore on Doki Birthday.
Ew, what is that hair hanging on?
Who decorated this place?
Oh, that door is open now.
Oh, it's like a little teddy bear!
It's like a little teddy bear!
Well, Doki, maybe you shouldn't have killed your kids.
I'm just saying.
It was roleplay!
She said it was roleplay!
Roleplay gone wrong, 3am.
Oh my god.
Do I have a reflection?
I'm a ghost.
No.
I'm a vampire.
I have a reflection.
I'm not a vampire.
I'm a vampire.
Vampire baby.
I mean, this seems like a happy family.
Maybe.
Is there anything in the closet?
Oh my god, these clothes hanging up.
I keep thinking they're people.
The bed looks so cozy.
I'm not gonna lie.
I know, right?
Like, oh, there's only one person in that bed.
What do you mean there's only one person?
Yeah, I mean like only one person got out of that bed.
Oh, the other person could be clean and they, you know, made their side of the bed.
Why are you turning lights off?
I don't know anymore.
Oh wait, the door downstairs opened.
Oh, we're gonna go into the cement.
Let's go down, down, down, down.
Down, down, down, down.
I wonder if I could just pay someone to like record me playing, like record me pretending to play the game.
And then I just put myself over the video.
This is for charity.
I'll pay the person to make the video.
Oh, it's your favorite, cement.
Yeah!
Okay, we got cement.
Doki hates children, confirmed.
Oh, 100%.
It did not have to be confirmed.
Wait, what was your charity for?
It was for mental health.
Oh, look, Jesus.
You could turn the light on.
We're still lit.
I think that's the room we're in.
Oh wait, there's a lady there.
That could be...
What room is that?
I can't turn it off now.
Wait, where's the...
What room is that?
That's Lucy, right?
Lucy?
How do I know how crazy I am right now?
I can't tell.
Do you have a brain?
The brain will show up in the bottom left.
Why are you pausing?
I can't tell if I'm crazy or not.
I can't tell.
How crazy am I?
The brain in the bottom left will show you.
It just shows red.
How do I know if I'm going crazy?
How would I know?
What if my crazy is my normal?
I don't know.
Well, take your meds.
You pick some up.
But Blake, I have limited meds.
I can't just take my meds.
I can't go over...
You know, if you take too much, you might overdose.
Well, if you actually play the game, then you'll progress and you won't have to take them so often.
Okay, you're right.
I think we have to go find her, no?
Yeah, but where's Cement?
Where would Cement be?
Cement?
Well, no, I don't think she's in Cement.
It's Shand.
Yeah, but why would I get Cement?
I saw a record player.
Did you see a record player anywhere?
Yeah, I saw that.
Can I just break the vases?
We gotta go find her.
If going down is up...
Oh, there you go.
You got it.
Yay!
How do you open doors?
Oh, it's pull.
Pull.
Keep pulling.
Oh, god.
Okay.
Yippee.
Open a door.
Hello?
Oh, god.
Who is...
What do you mean you need the basement key?
Who decorates this?
Yeah, who decorates this?
That is like...
It's like serial killer.
I mean, wait, he is though, actually.
Wait, you're right.
He did kill his family.
Yeah.
Oh, my god.
That's a light.
I thought that was a person.
If you look at this, it looks like a person.
I saw it.
It looked like a person.
You're in the corner.
Hello, am I in cement?
Cement.
Where is the light?
I think...
I think you should come back with a candle, no?
You're right.
You're gonna go crazy.
Try the other door.
Oh, wait.
I got a lighter.
Oh, nice.
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
Do not prevent stress build up, okay?
Standing in the dark with a lighter will decrease your character's sanity.
Okay, good to know.
But I still need to see what the fuck is going on.
Oh, I heard her.
Stop.
Did you hear her?
You don't hear her going...
No, I did.
You don't hear her?
Chat, did you hear that?
No, I did.
Doki, where are you looking?
Why aren't you moving?
Doki, come back to us.
I'm getting a voicemail.
Come back to us.
How do I...
What do you mean you're getting a voicemail?
How do I turn...
How do I turn this off?
Turn what
idea off?
I don't know.
Why would you want to?
Because it's limited.
The field is limited.
I don't think it is.
Sorry, they're still using my voicemail right now.
What are you talking about?
Your voicemail?
I got a call.
And they're leaving a voicemail because I didn't pick it up.
The voices are speaking to me.
How long is this voicemail?
Holy fuck.
It's still going.
I can't cancel it too because they're clearly leaving me a message right now.
You're like downloading the message.
Your mod is telling you to bring the volume up of the game.
I'm trying to breathe right now, one at a time.
I'm trying to remember how to breathe.
God damn, this voicemail is so long.
They're still leaving a voicemail right now.
I swear to God, this is an automated thing.
It's just running to the end right now.
I swear to fucking God.
It came from a toll-free number too, so I don't know.
It's probably one of those robots that don't call.
I think it's a robot call.
Should I just cancel it?
Nah.
What if it's a ghost calling you?
Lucy?
Lucy, is that you?
I wish a robot would call me.
I just saw you on TV a minute ago.
Oh my God, Lucy.
She's famous.
Oh my God, she's so famous.
Look, she didn't forget about the little people like us.
She's like, you're my biggest fan.
So I'm giving you a personalized DM.
I remember you supporting me when I was just in the underground cafes.
Hi, Doki Bird.
It's me, Lucy.
I'm actually... I know you're a huge fan of mine.
And actually, my car just broke down.
Do you think you could spare 20 bucks for me?
So I could Uber to a mechanic.
Don't worry, I'll pay you back.
And you'll definitely get the VIP tickets to my next performance.
Yeah, I'm Lucy, so you know I'm rich.
I just lost my wallet.
And don't worry about how this number is totally free.
You know, I'm just trying to save money, you know.
Alright, I'm canceling this voicemail.
I'm done.
Holy cow.
Wait, are you sure it's not you?
Do you have one of those like...
No.
Okay, it's me, Doki Bird.
No, I'm very... I'm very...
Okay, wait.
Let me double check if they actually... the voicemail actually...
Oh, they did not register.
I canceled on their voicemail.
Guys, I don't think I should have pressed canceled on the voicemail, guys.
Because they actually...
Google the number.
Okay, you're right.
I'm gonna Google the number.
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
It looks like you're a doctor.
Somebody like Doki Bird, this is the most important news.
We just got your test results and I...
Oh no, I Googled the number and it doesn't show up.
Oh, then it's... it's definitely...
It's definitely a toll-free?
Or like a scam?
Probably not.
What if it's like someone's personal number?
That's a toll-free service.
Well, what if you know them then?
I don't know.
Maybe it's like...
Maybe it...
Maybe it's from...
Definitely losing.
Maybe it's from the CRA.
The Canada Revenue...
That's our IRS, by the way.
That's the Canadian IRS.
Maybe it's the Canadian IRS calling me.
I think you should keep playing the game.
Okay.
Okay, I got this.
That's my suggestion.
You mean chat suggestion.
No, no, it's mine too.
I'm just saying.
How do I turn...
Guys, guys, I still haven't learned how...
Guys, I still didn't learn how to turn off my lighter, guys.
That was the whole reason why I paused.
How do I turn...
How do I turn off the lighter?
Guys, I can only swap hands.
Guys, the lighter is limited fuel.
How do I turn it off?
I can't.
I'm not stalling.
I don't know.
How do I close the lid?
How do I close the...
Man, you can't judge me.
You don't even know.
You aren't even helping me.
You don't even know the answer.
This is the first puzzle.
I've never played this game before.
How do you turn off the lighter?
And you don't know.
I've never played these games before.
How do I turn off the lighter?
Maybe you look at the controls.
It doesn't say how to turn off the lighter.
It just says door control.
I'm simple, please.
Move inventory slot Q.
What?
Where does it say Q?
Move inventory slot Q.
There's no Q in there.
It said under controls.
It didn't?
Okay.
But how do I turn off the lighter?
You just did.
Oh, I hold it.
Yeah, you just hold it, man.
Die.
Hello?
Oh, I hear her.
Stop.
You don't hear her?
No, I did.
I just pretend I didn't.
She's coming for you.
Put the toys back in their place.
No yelling.
Ask dad for the keys if you need some.
Don't try to go...
I'm not in the dark.
I'm in the candle.
No, remember it said...
Oh, that's the candle, yeah.
I think she's right in there.
Yeah, she's right there.
Maybe give her a toy.
Oh, why would you do that?
Oh no, I thought the TV will turn on.
La la la la la la.
Oh, I'm in the dark for too long.
No, you're in the light of the...
What if you go in there?
Oh my god, she's doing laundry.
What a woman.
The light turned on.
The door opened.
Oh, the light turned on.
See, she's still helping you out, actually.
Hello, Lucy?
Caution.
Do not enter.
Read backside.
Kids, you need something, go ask dad in his office upstairs.
Okay, dad.
Who's taking pictures, creep?
Oh!
Hello?
Teacher warning.
Is she coming?
Did she show up in the camera?
Lucy?
Lucy, did you call me?
Lucy, you have something to say?
What?
Oh, there's the trail.
Oh, nasty.
Hello, Lucy.
Oh, I got goosebumps right now.
Maybe you should follow it.
Oh, there's like a little drawing.
Yeah, what if I just go right side?
Bye, Lucy.
Okay.
Goodbye, Lucy.
She says...
And I never come back.
Teacher warning.
It's too fast.
I can't process this.
Yeah, how do we process this correctly?
What's that sound?
I think that's Lucy.
What's going on in there?
This house is too big.
You see that?
Oh, yeah, I see that.
We see... what if we just never meet Lucy?
You could do that.
Oh, it's leading you there.
Yeah, see?
It's literally pointing in that direction.
We're like... not following horrible...
Oh, never mind.
It led me all the way back here.
That's what I told you!
Just go try.
Oh, wait.
Quick save.
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
Okay, F5.
There we go.
What if I just walk up to you?
Hey, Lucy.
Oh, she's getting up.
Oh, she won't let me get near her.
Let me near you.
Lucy, hey!
Oh, do you have a candle for me?
Oh, she just gave that to you.
See?
She's nice.
Why are you looking away?
Goodbye, Lucy and Lucy.
Oh, there she goes.
She's moonwalking away.
Bye, Lucy!
She disappears.
Okay, now I can move forward.
What is that?
She gave you... Oh, it's a syringe.
Okay, this game cannot save.
Save manually if needed.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I need to save.
We literally just tried... Oh, it disappeared.
Into my slide I go.
Alright, guys.
I don't like this camera because it's like...
What was that?
Finish your basement.
They make like the biggest house ever and can't even finish their basement?
I have a lot of stuff going on in my life right now.
I still haven't unpacked by the way ever since I'm moon.
And then my noose ends in like 2-3 months, I think.
What?
Wait.
Oh, that's just a shadow.
That's just a shadow.
Wait, who builds a house like you?
Oh my god.
Who builds a house like this?
I think I'm in the backside of the house.
Seizure warning, everybody.
Seizure warning.
You wanted Lucy chapter!
Oh my... Wow.
My brain.
Say hi to her.
My brain is not doing so well.
What do you mean?
I need to take my meds.
Oh, I think you do, yeah.
It's okay.
The less I see my brain, the healthier I am.
Uh-huh.
This is like my only source of light.
Which is like not good because...
I'm sorry.
Seizure warning.
Why did the music stop?
I can be alone in my thoughts.
I don't think I can.
I feel like there should be more items that I'm not picking up.
Yeah.
Oh, there you go.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh.
Oh, like that?
You can pick up...
You can pick up fucking cans?
I don't know.
You can sell them for something.
I hate this.
I fucking hate this.
Why is the music...
Why is the ambiance gone?
I hate this.
It's way too quiet.
That means something's gonna happen.
Why are these drawers...
Oh my god, I scared myself.
I guess I'm trying to help.
Open it up.
Oh, a lightbulb.
Nice.
Oh my god, I need this.
You need that?
Lightbulb, good.
What's in there?
Oh guys, you wanna know what it looks like when the gamma ray is all the way up?
Oh, actually, I kind of am curious.
This game is less scary now.
Wait.
There it is.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I can see everything.
Oh my god, you can see everything.
All I'm saying is, past Doki knows what's up.
You couldn't even start the game and you had it this high?
Yeah.
Oh my god, I don't need to use the camera anymore.
I think you took those cans.
I'm not gonna lie.
I think they were in your inventory.
Wait, are they?
No, they're not.
Oh, wait, they are.
What am I gonna do with the cans?
I told you.
Bureau o'clock.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
Your pills were like...
Oh, your brain is doing really bad.
Oh, wait.
It's not doing so well.
Let me...
Okay.
Don't worry, I have two.
Double the...
The other pills were like floating around.
Okay.
Don't worry, let me turn the camera back.
It was like here, right?
Right here.
Alright.
Sure.
Press accept.
Okay.
Okay, let's keep going.
You cannot store this.
Oh, wait.
Wait, which is this?
I think you used all your pills.
This one?
Alright.
Okay.
Keep going.
I would walk around.
Instead of using this, I would walk around with the lighter.
Okay, but what if something interesting happens?
Why did you do that?
I don't know.
Wait, I dropped my lighter.
Why do you have the can?
Where did my lighter go?
Oh, your brain is getting bad again.
Is this my lighter?
There it is.
Okay.
Hello?
Oh, you have the basement key.
Where am I?
I have no idea.
This house is nuts.
I'm so confused.
Hello?
Oh, we just made a circle.
That's where we saw Lucy.
This is...
Oh, the storage room.
Any dynamic items?
Just open the door.
Okay.
What was that?
Lucy?
Daddy's not happy.
Lucy, you're gonna get the gun again.
You don't want me to bring back Roleplay.
What did they hate?
They hated this guy so much they hung his picture in the storage closet.
Oh my god, what is that big thing?
Oh, I could've turned on the lights.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna clock.
You're gonna clock.
You don't like it when daddy brings out the gun.
I don't think the lighter has fuel.
There's no fuel gauge.
No, it does.
It does have fuel.
Where?
I don't see it.
This light is not broken.
Oh, turn it on.
It was broken.
Someone's tummy is growling.
Wait, you should go read these.
Okay, read the rules.
Put the toys back in their place.
You can't touch the toys.
Yes, you can.
Oh, you can't use that.
Oh, it's because I'm holding the light.
Or the light bulb.
Yeah, the light bulb.
Wait, now you switch it out with the lighter.
So you have to have a hand free, I think.
Yeah, but I have to have my other hand with the meds or I'm gonna hear the voices again.
Oh, hey.
What's that?
It's the light.
Oh, you found a candle.
Candles that can be moved around with a candle will cause it to extinguish.
They last a long time and act to help increase your...
Oh, wait, I like that.
You can put one right there.
Where is one?
You just grabbed it.
I know, but where do I put it?
Turn around, back in that room.
In here?
Yeah, you can put it there.
Yeah, but that's a waste.
There's a lot of...
Yeah, that's a waste though.
I feel it.
So, like, I should just hold on to it until...
Until I don't.
I would put it in your inventory.
No, no, my meds!
No!
No, the price of pharmaceuticals is getting higher!
Jokey.
I don't have insurance!
Oh, there's another light bulb.
Wait a minute.
Oh, my God.
Is there anything in there?
Oh, wait.
That's where I keep my bodies.
Just real play, guys.
Just real play.
I'm so lost.
It did say on the electrical room...
It said that you should go upstairs and ask dad for the keys or whatever, so maybe...
You can go get the...
The room key upstairs.
You made a good point and I'm not gonna listen to you.
What just happened?
How did I go crazy?
Yeah, what was that sound?
I don't know and I don't like it.
Huh?
Okay, let's go upstairs.
I'm not gonna look back.
Nice.
Now I'm less crazy.
Oh, gross.
Is it this?
That one requires the basement key.
You have the basement key.
You just locked me out like that?
You can do that?
No.
Hold.
Maybe it's push.
Push.
Well, let me...
Oh, my God.
I'm locked out.
Doki doesn't know how to open doors.
No, I'm actually locked out.
Oh, wait.
It was this way.
Oh, you're not.
I'm back.
Yeah.
This house is so brightly lit.
We're fine.
Okay.
Oh.
No.
Where did I go?
Lucy?
Daddy's confused.
Lucy.
Daddy doesn't know where to go, Lucy.
I think you gotta go upstairs, no?
Or you gotta go to daddy's study.
Daddy's home?
Daddy's home.
Why are the lights so flickering up here?
I don't know.
What was that?
Whisper guys.
Oh, I hear some whispering.
It was only coming from the bathroom.
As soon as you stepped away, it stopped.
Yeah, I'm not going back there.
Hello?
This is...
It might be broken.
Why is it broken?
Space kid.
Use your gun.
So true.
That's right.
I don't know what one thing that ghosts are afraid of.
What?
Bullets.
Who's gonna tell her?
Tell me what?
Oh hey, this leads to the bathroom.
Oh, okay.
Hello?
No, hello.
Turn it on.
Turn it...
Okay.
They're just trying to save electricity.
Oh, you're right.
I'm using too much of the electricity right now.
I think they just turned the lights off again.
Oh, they're fine.
They're fine.
What is that?
It's coming from the sink.
Oh no, wait.
I hear something.
It's coming from the sink.
I'm scared.
I don't know where to go.
It's just the roaches.
I'm lost.
Confused.
Try and find the study.
Oh, the camera.
Oh my god, I forgot about the camera.
Oh, wait.
Hello?
Wow, wow, wow.
Oh, it's going towards the whispers.
Why are you crawling up?
I don't like this.
You got some pills though.
Pills here.
Pills here?
I would put...oh wait, you used your candle.
Just kidding.
Try and find a way to turn on the lights.
See, I told you it's limited.
See?
What's limited?
The fuel.
I just got another one.
I think that's in case you don't get the first one.
No, I'm pretty sure the fuel is limited.
Wait, what's that?
That was some lore.
It's a fucking newspaper.
I'm not going to read that.
Lucy, daddy's not happy.
Lucy?
Daddy's not happy.
Daddy's getting pretty mad.
Wait, did the door just open?
Oh, it was open.
It was open already?
Daddy is disappointed in you, Lucy.
What was the point of coming in?
It just opened.
Did you hear that?
Yeah, I did.
Something opened.
You could see if...you could change the light bulb out.
Oh, that's true.
There's no light bulbs here.
What about the lamp?
No, that's for candles.
I don't have an extra one.
No, no, the lamp.
The one with the lamp.
Wait, is the safe open?
I don't think so.
No, it's locked.
Lucy, daddy's gonna go a little cuckoo.
Well, that was pointless.
Yeah, that was pointless.
What was the point of...like, what opened?
Everything else is locked here.
Lucy, I'm getting a little annoyed.
Oh, it's red now.
Wait, there's mist.
A basement.
It's gun o'clock.
It's gun o'clock!
At 335.
Daddy brings out the gun.
It's not 335.
Oh, is this a cutscene?
Yeah.
Oh, I'm outside.
Oh, thank god.
Nothing bad ever happens outside.
Does that say kill?
Oh, yeah!
A little heavy, huh?
This is high quality graphics, by the way.
Guys, the rain is so realistic.
Oh my god, it's lagging so bad on Discord.
Wait, really?
Wait, am I on, like, the highest?
No, you're not on the highest.
Oh, I'm not?
Okay.
No.
Just wanna be sure.
At least, like... Am I, like... Wait, actually, what's, like, my graphics settings right now?
High, but not the highest.
Oh, wait.
Now we're extra quality.
Oh, the bitrate might... The bitrate's probably dying because of the...
The rain.
Rain, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's not anything we can really do about that.
Oh, hey, look.
See?
Everything's okay now.
Guys, we're outs... Oh, look, there's Lucy Toys!
Look at that!
Look, she has a little turtle.
Hello, Lucy.
This is so not scary.
Yeah, see?
It's not scary anymore.
We're outside!
You could get through this chapter so easily.
You know what?
You're right.
Let me take another sip, just in case.
Are you fe... Oh, there's the panda!
Oh, yeah, there's the panda!
Wait, can I go crazy in here?
Turn anti-alias on?
Does that help?
Someone's like, please don't get sweared again!
What does that even do?
Very high.
Does it make the game better?
It's gonna make it look like it's a AAA title.
Whoa.
It looks the same.
Call of Duty.
Alright.
Oh, there's a giant panda!
Oh my gosh, she really fucking loves pandas.
Yeah.
Lucy, are you okay, Lucy?
Oh my gosh, I see the panda.
Yeah, I know.
There's so many pandas.
I know, she's like a peeping tom, peeking out of that tree.
Peeping panda.
Yeah, peeping panda.
Ew, stalker panda.
Why is there so many toys?
If you weren't so creepy, maybe you wouldn't be endangered.
Oh, that's true.
You know how they don't know how to talk?
They don't know how to have sex.
What?
Yeah, they're like...
Because there's a really low birth rate of pandas, that's why they're endangered.
And zoos in China have to play panda porn to help them get them in the mood.
Wait, you didn't know that?
No!
No, yeah, so they don't...
So they only mate once every couple of years or some shit?
There's only a specific time frame that they'll actually get busy.
But a lot of male pandas don't want to do it.
Pandas are so lucky that they're cute, otherwise nobody would be going through this trouble.
So when it's the time of the year, they have to play panda porn just to show them how it's done and get them in the mood.
Oh my god!
I'm kind of concerned why, like, what is that named?
Like, is it named, like, on somebody's computer?
Just panda porn dot mp4?
Panda hub.
Oh, I'm Lucy.
I'm Lucy.
Hey, Lucy.
I want to be your friend, Lucy.
No!
Oh, the ghost comes out?
Friend did it.
Pico, what happened to Pico?
Pico?
Why is she gone?
Lucy, what happened to him?
Oh, someone says only pandas.
Only pandas.
Do you think they could use other bears?
She's like...
Are you a polar bear type of panda or are you a brown bear or a black bear?
What kind of panda do you think you want to watch?
It's just, you know, what if they don't have a preference for pandas?
Are you a moon bear?
They just see, like, bear porn and they're just like, yeah, that's all I need.
That's all I need.
Now I'm in the mood.
Also, like, they're so stupid that if you...
You can, like...
Okay, so, like, it's very...
Like, it's very rare for a panda to have twins or something.
So, like, when a panda gets twins, they have to...
They can't comprehend that they have more than one child.
So they, like, swap...
They have to, like, swap the babies back and forth.
So, like, she would take care of both of them at the same time.
That's like...
Wow.
No, what?
How do I progress this?
Oh, wait, there's a...
Oh, there you go.
I need a small key.
You need the small key.
I have a basement key.
Is it in the drawer?
Oh, maybe.
Oh, I can't open it.
Am I, like...
Am I not supposed to be there?
Maybe you can go back.
I don't wanna go back.
This area is nice.
If you come here a second time, it's fine.
Oh, check the pictures.
I'm Lucy.
Hi, Lucy.
Lucy.
I like my new...
Oh, there it is.
Oh.
I wanna be your friend, Lucy.
Yeah, Lucy, I wanna be your friend.
Sorry for talking about pandas.
Oh.
Oh my...
Oh, this is what she gave you.
Oh, yeah.
She's on men's.
Wait, okay.
Wait, what does it say?
Oh, investigate it.
Pick it up.
Oh, yeah.
Did I just look away?
Oh, it just says Lucy.
Lucy.
Really?
Okay.
Oh, it's getting darker.
I don't like that.
Really?
How do we save the pandas?
Is there any other way we can do?
Huh?
Get rid of the pandas?
No!
Not the pandas!
What do we get rid of?
Get rid of what?
What do you don't want?
The bird?
A bird?
Pico?
Pico!
Why do we get rid of Pico?
Oh, she's crying.
Lucy.
Do it, Lucy.
Get rid of Lucy.
Oh, I should save.
Oh, okay.
You always pick the best part.
Do what?
I think he wants you to do something.
What do I do?
She's just crying.
Do I just listen to her cry?
That's right, cry, Lucy.
That's right.
Hello!
Goodbye!
Did I fall down?
Oh.
You took too many meds.
Yeah, just a little hallucination, guys.
Why did she do that?
That's so weird.
Oh, wait, it's auto-save.
Typical Sunday.
Okay, now what do I do?
Flash.
Oh, it's standing in the dark.
I'm not trying to!
Why doesn't the TV count as not the dark?
Yeah.
Oh, wait, she really did take off.
Wait, can you not turn on the light?
Turn around.
I don't know where the light switch is.
Right there.
That's so fucked up, Lucy.
Daddy's not happy anymore.
Daddy's very disappointed.
Daddy's disappointed.
Wait, look to the left.
I think you can follow the light covers.
Oh, wait, you're right.
Daddy's going to his cabinet.
Daddy likes the light covers, Lucy.
Daddy needs the light covers to function, Lucy.
Daddy paid good money for the light covers, Lucy.
Lucy, are you going to go to Home Depot and fix this?
I think not, Lucy.
Turn it off.
God, shut up.
Shut up, Lucy.
I think it goes upstairs.
Oh, it does.
God damn it, Lucy.
That was at least $10 of light covers.
My sanity is decreasing.
Oh, shit, wait.
Lucy, Daddy's not happy.
Daddy doesn't have insurance, Lucy.
Your light is nearly out.
Okay, maybe you were right.
Okay, let me...
Your lighter is empty.
That was so fast.
Okay, bye.
Just set the place on fire.
Wait, how are we supposed to see?
Oh, I hear her.
This is where the light covers go.
Where did it go?
I think she's in that room, though.
I'm not looking back.
There she is.
Only pills will keep you sane at this point.
There she is, yeah.
Daddy can't see.
Daddy can't see, Lucy.
Daddy's confused.
Oh, maybe you just follow her so you hear her.
I can't see anything!
Use your ear!
You don't need to see!
I can!
Wait, do I have more light?
Oh.
I have another one.
Oh, nice.
There we go.
Okay...
I hear her around this side.
I hear her maybe in this room.
Yeah.
Is she taking a shower?
Sorry, Lucy.
How do I close this?
Can you die from insanity?
I think you can.
Where did she come from?
Wait, is this a death?
Wait, is that death?
Got your mouth!
Lucy!
What did I do?
What did we do there?
I don't know.
She got my mouth.
No more kisses, Lucy.
She was all mouth.
Oh my God.
No more goodnight.
Where am I?
Where are you?
I don't remember.
Oh, here.
Okay, so it auto-saved at the...
What the?
Maybe she's coming to get you.
She was like, no!
Do you leave?
You could probably go...
I'm not okay right now.
I'm not okay.
What the fuck?
Oh my God, I'm taking my...
I didn't know I wasn't okay!
Oh, is my sanity really bad?
Oh, maybe I should not have watched.
Oh, wait, is she hunting me?
Oh, she might be.
Oh, I might have gone a little too crazy.
Lucy, please, I didn't know.
I didn't know I was going crazy.
Oh my gosh, she took my nose again.
Got your nose.
She says this is after every time you've taken my nose.
Take your pills.
Right now.
Oh, she has a cat.
No, don't take my nose again!
Okay, so I don't think I'm this bad anymore.
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait.
Wait, I figured it out.
Wait, no, I know what to do.
I know what to do.
You do?
Okay, I know.
What if you go hide in the closet?
There's two closets to hide.
Yes, there is the one that was in her room.
Okay, wait, wait.
Someone said take pictures of her.
Okay.
She just hobbles so much.
She's a little vain.
Let me take my pills first.
Yeah, take your pills.
Is it a chase sequence?
No.
I can't see anything.
Me too, I'm a little scared.
She's gonna come hobbling at us again.
Okay, maybe she...
Oh, this room is normal.
Maybe she won't.
What if she opens the door?
She just comes in.
I'll take another pill then.
Just to be safe.
You're gonna lose all your sanity hiding in the dark.
Okay, but Lucy's hunting me.
I don't hear her.
I don't know that.
Where do I go?
Where are you supposed to go?
Yeah.
I did the thing they told me to do.
It's not a waste.
I literally had her chasing me for like 20 years.
She took the light covers.
What the fuck?
From everywhere.
Wow.
Lucy sucks.
She took everything.
She took the house.
Someone said parents' bedroom.
Guys, why didn't you tell me that sooner?
Oh, the lights are back on.
Oh, there she is.
Go to the parents' bedroom.
This is not the parents' bedroom.
Lucy.
What did you expect?
I don't know.
I left the doors.
I left the doors to keep her out.
I don't know.
I thought she would just, you know, be like, oh, she's busy.
I'll come back later.
Lucy, daddy's in his study now.
Yeah.
Lucy, you're not allowed in daddy's study.
Lucy, you can't just phase through.
Why would she no clip through the door?
Lucy is reclaiming her part of the will.
Okay.
Okay, before I get...
Before she fucking kicks my nose again.
Guys, what do I do?
What do we do, guys?
What do we do?
How do we get out of...
How do we get out of Lucy?
How does she stop?
Lucy's after the insurance money.
Oh my god.
Dude, did you hear about the Ghost Adventures guy and his wife?
Wait, what?
No.
What about him?
Also, who are they?
There's one guy on the show Ghost Adventures.
His name is Aaron.
And recently it came out that his wife was plotting his murder.
What?
Yeah.
She took his life insurance and stuff?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She was working with some guy who was a murderer in jail and was just like plotting the guy's murder.
Holy shit!
Yeah, this all happened really recently.
And...
Like, how do you, like, did she just randomly send a letter?
Like, she just looked up, like, recent murderers that are about to...
She saw him in a true crime documentary.
Also, like, how long has he been in jail for?
Because don't, like, they stay in jail for, like, mostly for life?
So how the fuck is he gonna get out of jail and kill him?
Yeah, I was gonna say, like, how is he gonna get out of jail to kill him?
I thought they'd be, like, there for life.
And if they do get out, like, wouldn't they be on parole?
Like, with an ankle bracelet?
Maybe they thought...
Maybe she was just like, he knows some people.
I don't know.
Life is 25 years?
Imagine murdering someone and only getting 25 years.
Imagine you're also just like, hey, I wanna murder this guy.
I'm gonna wait 25...
The most premeditated murder.
Yeah, yeah.
It's being like, oh my, no, she looks up for...
No, what's like that murder?
Oh my god, maybe he committed his murder, like, 24 years and 11 months ago.
And he was about to get out of jail.
He's like, see you next month, baby.
See you next month.
Murderers are about to get out of jail.
What?
25 is the minimum.
Oh, I mean, that's still like...
I guess if it's like an accidental murder.
So like...
Like, well, it was an oopsie.
So like, 25 years.
Anyway, sorry.
I don't know why I thought about that.
What do we do, guys?
Someone made a good point.
Like, they failed.
They got made into a true crime documentary, which means they failed the murder.
What do you mean?
Because, like, they got caught.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
They got caught.
Yeah, so like, why would this...
It's like, don't worry.
You know what to do to avoid getting caught this time.
Oh, this time, yeah.
They know what mistakes not to make.
Yeah, they know the mistakes they made so they can hide the trail better.
Okay, guys, what do we do?
We're stuck.
We're stuck in a death loop.
Someone did say the bedroom, but it was one guy.
I don't know if we're going to get one more.
Yeah, we're going to get one guy.
Guys, what do we do?
Guys, this will be the fifth time.
You run down the stairs.
To where, then?
Yeah, I was down the stairs, and then she came after me.
Then you went back upstairs.
Don't die.
Run and hide.
But where?
Where do I hide?
Trying to talk things out with Lucy.
I did.
I closed the door on her.
How much more do I have to do?
Tell her to go to her room.
Oh, parent's bedroom closet is the...
Oh, hey, the one guy here.
I looked up the guide.
Okay.
All right, parent's bedroom.
I know where that is.
Can we bribe her with more light switches?
Can I see your favorite thing, girl?
Come here, girl.
Come on.
I just leave a trail light.
Come on, Lucy.
It's right here.
Lucy.
Come on, Lucy.
To the parent's room.
I think you might have to wait until she is...
Until she is chasing you, no?
No, I think she chases me when I'm crazy.
Okay, then I will go.
Okay, she still took the light cover.
You tried.
I'm in the closet now, Lucy.
I think you need to shut the door.
Oh, when Lucy is chasing me?
I think I hear her.
Did you hear?
I don't hear.
Lucy.
I thought I heard breathing.
Wait, they lied.
There is nothing here.
They are forcing you into the closet.
I don't want to go in the closet.
I hear something.
You don't hear that?
I do, but I'm pretending I don't.
You have to start the chase.
Okay.
Oh, someone said quick save now.
That's a good idea, actually.
Oh, no.
Then I already wasted meds, so I'd rather not.
Okay, nevermind.
It's fine.
We don't...
Just don't forget to shut the door of the closet, okay?
Okay.
I'm gonna forget.
Wait.
Use your lighter instead.
Why is she chasing me now?
Maybe I should just die.
Why is she chasing me?
Lucy!
Daddy's mad!
Chase me!
Lucy, I'm reinstalling the light switches!
Oh my God, Lucy!
Guess who found new light switches?
Lucy?
Maybe she really hated the ones, actually.
Okay, Lucy.
Come on, Lucy!
Lucy, chase!
Chase!
Come on!
Chase, Lucy!
Chase!
Oh, man.
I should've...
You're gonna regret doing this.
You're gonna have to loop her now.
Yeah, no.
I should just die.
Maybe if I just stand there, then she just gets my nose again.
Wait, she's not hunting me at all.
Oh, there she is.
Oh, there she goes!
Go, go, go!
To the bathroom!
Goodbye, Lucy!
Don't look!
Don't look at her!
Just go!
Goodbye!
If you fuck this up, I'm gonna be so mad.
Hello?
Lucy?
Where is she?
Wait, she didn't come in.
That's right, this is the daddy's room.
Daddy's room.
That's right.
You're not allowed in daddy's room.
Wait, she didn't come in.
Wait.
What was that?
There's another door in here?
Oh, it goes to the kid's room.
Why is there a door to Lucy's room in their closet?
Just to make sure Lucy's okay.
In the closet?
Oh!
I should turn this off though.
Okay.
Oh wait, that's the birdcage!
Oh my God, Pico!
Pico!
Wait, no.
How do I...
I'm struggling to go through a hole.
The hole is the goal!
Pico!
Is my sanity okay?
It's like pink.
It's fine.
Okay.
Pico!
Hello!
Hello everybody!
Oh, there's been a lot of Pico's in there.
Oh my God, how many Pico's?
Okay, I think she's gonna be chasing you in here.
Yeah, I think so too.
What am I supposed to do?
Leave?
Use your lighter.
Like, actually be able to see.
What's the fun in that?
Okay, if you wanna be playing this game for actual literal years...
Yeah, and then you'll be there with me.
I have...
Did you see that?
Oh, there's the exit.
Am I supposed to open these?
Maybe.
Hey there!
Oh, I think this is a stealth portion.
I would go.
Go to the door.
Where is she going?
It's locked.
Where is she?
She just disappeared.
She actually did just disappear.
She never came back.
Is that her?
Oh, she doesn't know.
She's stupid.
Oh God, our child is dumb.
Oh no, you did this.
I told you not to sign her up to those classes.
I think she's coming for you.
You're not stupid, sweetie.
Sweetie, daddy's just joking.
Should've signed her up for Kumon, damn it.
Daddy's just fucking around.
You know, daddy's being a little silly goofball.
Go find the... Oh, there she is.
She's camping.
That's not fair.
Like, I can't see anything, too.
Use the lighter.
Yeah, but it's limited.
I can't see.
Yeah, but this is the part.
This is when you should use it.
Yeah, but like, I can't see, like, close enough.
Where did she go?
Guys, guys, guys.
Can I cheat, guys?
I think here you can cheat.
Yeah, guys, come on.
I'm thinking about seizure warnings, okay, guys?
I'm thinking about the seizure warning.
I mean, you do have a lighter.
Yeah, but it's limited.
The game is not paused.
Where did she go?
I don't know.
Like, the thing is, like...
Like, this gives me more view ahead, though.
That's the thing.
I hear her.
Can I open this?
Yeah, okay, I opened all these.
There must be something in these drawers.
Like, why else would...
I sure hope that it doesn't, like, it stays in the same spot every time.
If you die, you know what I mean?
Oh, there's some drawers to the right.
To the right, to the right.
To your left.
Left.
There, there.
No.
No?
There's something... There's a place over here.
Oh, there's... Right there, right there.
Yeah, right to the... There, there, yeah, yeah.
Look inside.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
Yay!
Lucy?
Lucy.
Daddy.
Daddy not happy.
Daddy wants to go home.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
That's so stupid.
Oh, nevermind.
I was gonna say, I don't think she's gonna get you anymore.
Wait, I can run.
You can?
Sorry, Lucy, I leave now.
I think you should run now.
Seems like the perfect...
I've been casually walking this entire time.
Uh-uh.
I'm not looking back.
Pico!
I don't think that's Pico.
Wait, what is that?
Pico?
Oh, it's like a little...
Yeah, but...
I can't turn it on.
It's a little wooden bird.
Pico?
Nah, keep going then.
Keep going.
Pico?
I don't think Pico.
Wait, it's jammed.
Under the blood?
Why can't I turn it on, Pico?
Pico, talk to me.
Take a picture.
No, it doesn't flash anymore.
Wait, there's something...
Hello?
Pico?
Pico!
Pico disappeared.
Wait, there's no doors.
Hello?
Oh, there's a little girl in the corner.
Lucy?
Lucy, what happened to Pico?
She's eating the bird.
Take a picture.
I'm trying to.
Hi, Lucy.
Daddy's not mad.
Daddy's...
Can you use the...
Oh, nevermind.
Okay.
Oh, the other door disappeared.
Oh, yeah.
There's another door.
I don't really think she ate the bird.
She might have thought it was chicken.
There's a little bit of an affinity for chicken.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
It could just be like chicken.
Oh, look, there's Pico!
Oh!
We can eat it too.
Wait, where'd it go?
Wait, where'd it...
Oh, I got it through the fucking cabinet.
Oh, there's three Picos.
And a sexy bust.
Hello.
Why are these...
Whoa.
Are you okay, Lucy?
I don't think so.
Lucy, do I need to take you to a doctor?
Chicken jockey!
You know there's a Minecraft live event?
A Minecraft...
That's based off the movie and if you finish it, you get a special Minecraft movie cape.
Wait, you didn't hear about it?
A cape?
Yeah, it ends on April 14th.
Or maybe...
I heard they extended it, but I don't know when it actually ends.
I'm gonna look it up.
Oh, hey.
Oh, look, it's her!
Hello!
Oh no, it's the friend!
It's her best friend, remember?
Oh yeah, oh!
Snapshot!
Oh damn, they're smart.
She's like, that's my best friend!
Is that the end of the chapter?
I don't think so.
I'm just hurt.
Oh, he's moaning.
Hello!
Minecraft.
Oh.
I got a jaw.
Oh, you got a little chin.
Yeah, oh, a jaw.
What do I do with this?
Good question.
Why the fuck did she take all the light covers?
Like, what am I gonna do?
I think she's coming.
What the hell was that?
What was that?
Um...
Just some paranormal activity.
Freaked out.
Oh, people are telling you to save, maybe.
What the fuck was that?
I feel like it probably auto-saved, though, guys.
Yeah, I'm pretty much pretty sure.
I'm cat word right now, I'm not okay.
Minecraft movie.
How to get the Minecraft movie event cape.
The yarn cape.
Oh, it's this event, though.
Yeah.
It's basically Overwatch.
Wait, is it?
I don't know what it is.
It seems fun.
Is it?
Wait, um...
Isn't there a mode in Overwatch where you have to, like, protect the payload?
Oh, wait, is it actually just that?
I heard there's, like, three different events, but you get to meet Steve!
Oh, boy.
Wait, but we're missing a mannequin that's missing his jaw?
Guys, you think I remember that?
Wait, this door opened.
I don't even remember seeing a mannequin ever.
Me too.
Wait, I'm in the kitchen now.
I have not been paying attention.
Oh, I accidentally took my meds.
That was not the right item.
Oopsie.
Well, it's dark.
It's probably fine.
Wasn't it in the basement?
Was it?
That would make sense, no?
Yeah, but this door opened, though.
That didn't...
Oh.
Oh, it's on the other side.
For the kitchen.
Did she take every light cover?
Every single one around this house.
Like, Lucia.
Lucia's evil.
Lucia.
This is why we shouldn't have homeschooled her.
Wait, how tall is she?
We can take her.
Check the...
What the hell?
It, like, ricocheted me above.
You're really excited about this.
Like, all I'm saying is that if we put her in a...
Oh my god, that was my pills.
If we put her in...
Oh, it scared me, too.
All I'm saying is that Chisha went to...
Went to a normal school instead of being homeschooled.
Then she wouldn't be a freak right now.
No, I think...
I think it's literally this house that she grew up in.
This is, like, whoever...
I actually took my pills again.
I took my last pills.
Okay.
I can't.
Put them away.
You're addicted.
I have a problem.
I have all these light bulbs.
But, like, I have all these...
We can't turn on any of them.
I can't turn on anything.
Wait, check the fridge.
Check the fridge.
It's on.
This is not okay, Lucy.
This looks like Homer Simpson's fridge.
Lucy, I am not happy right now.
Lucy, daddy can't even crack a cold one.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
Can you use that again?
You can.
I would take it.
Okay, nevermind.
Yeah, nevermind.
I got too lazy.
We're looking for the... Wait!
Remember the sexy bust behind the light?
What?
There, there.
In that room.
See, this is why I have you around.
You went the wrong way, though.
You said that room.
The one with the light.
The light.
That one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
In there, in there, in there.
See?
There was a sexy...
I'll never forget a sexy body.
Yeah, but it has to be missing a jaw.
It is missing its head.
Oh, see?
Oh, wait.
We got the jaw.
It's not here.
It's gone now.
Guys, I'm standing in the dark.
That's not good.
I hear rats.
Nah, it's just termites.
I hear termites.
That's definitely...
What is that?
What is that one mansion that's in California that the lady built because she was trying to run from her demons?
Oh my...
Oh, you have...
Yeah, you have the basement.
This must be the other door that you could not unlock earlier.
Oh.
Oh, it's not.
No, it's here.
Yeah, the Winchester house.
The Winchester house?
What is that?
It's literally...
Oh, my lighter is nearly empty.
Oh, that's not good.
That's not good.
It's bugged out.
Yeah, it's bugged out.
Don't worry about it then.
Basically, the Winchester house...
So, this lady was like...
She can't be in front of me, right?
Right, guys?
Go to the light in here, maybe.
Guys, my lighter is empty.
Daddy's hungry.
That's daddy's daddy.
Continue the story, Mint?
Okay.
So, she was like either the daughter or some descendant of a gun maker.
What?
Because of that, she felt a lot of guilt because the guns were used to kill people.
And so, she thought that she was being haunted by these demons.
And so, she built this house.
And it's like nonsensical.
There's stairs that lead to nowhere.
Oh, yeah.
So, the ghosts won't lead towards her or some shit.
She was the wife.
Thank you.
Okay, just kill me.
Just kill me.
I'm going crazy.
And I'll stand in this corner and you can do whatever you want.
What is this monster that's actually coming out?
Oh, my sanity is not so good right now.
I don't know.
I don't know where the fucking thing is.
I wanna see the monster.
I wanna see what is happening.
Where is it?
Where is the mannequin?
Where is the sexy jawless mannequin?
I'll stand here.
She's got a sexy jawline.
I'm crazy right now.
I have no pills.
You walked past it.
Was it the one at the light before?
Because I saw one there.
Was it there?
That one?
You didn't put the jaw on it.
Oh, it was that one?
Only pills will keep you.
Okay, kill me now so I can restart my journey.
Yeah, I think that would be smarter.
I wanna see whatever it is.
Yeah, I know.
I'm just sitting here.
Is it not gonna hunt me?
Wait, is that a lighter?
No way.
At least I know where the lighter is.
At least I know it's there.
This game is actually pretty generous.
Stop flashing.
Stop flashing it, Doki.
I didn't know that.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
It was like right behind you.
It came from the wall.
I was like, if I stand in this corner, at least I know it's approaching me.
It's right behind me, isn't it?
She's right behind me.
What?
That thing does not sound like or look like it should be making that noise.
It teleports behind you.
Alright, I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back.
She's asleep.
There she goes.
How much more?
Do we have to find the head too?
For this mannequin?
Are you spooked?
Give us more ideas for what?
What do you mean more ideas?
What do you mean?
Hi Minto.
Let's all smack talk.
You're all... Wait, I was gonna say all bark and no bite, but she's a cat.
You're all bark and no bite.
Did they give up?
No!
Doki is going to the bathroom.
I'm here.
I bought some banana bread earlier.
I kind of want to eat that.
I kind of want to go get that.
Banana bread.
Solid snake.
Get it with butter?
I've never had banana bread with butter.
You're all meow and no scratch.
Exactly.
She's... Oh wait.
She's rebooting.
What's life changing?
People in my chat was like, it's life changing.
You gotta try it with butter.
I told them I got banana bread earlier and they said try it with butter.
Wait, what?
Really?
I thought you can just eat banana bread on it's own.
I've always just had it on it's own.
And I'm really red right now.
Oh wait, you just broke the seal.
I broke the what?
The seal.
What's the seal?
When you drink and then you go to the bathroom for the first time, now you're gonna have to go to the bathroom every two seconds.
Oh, that's true.
That's gonna be me.
Wait, did someone take a bite out of my pizza?
No, okay, no, I didn't.
It was just baked wrong.
Who else would be taking a bite out of your pizza?
Lucy?
Lucy, did you take a bite out of daddy's special pizza?
Lucy, that pizza was laced with daddy's special medicine.
Lucy, you shouldn't have done that.
I almost said special sauce, but I think that was not gonna be very good.
No, no, no, no.
He's like, I want pizza too.
He's not getting pizza, it's my pizza.
Give him what he wants.
The dad craves pizza.
He won't stop pizza.
Okay, while you eat your pizza, I'm gonna go get banana bread.
I don't have any butter left.
Uber, eat some butter right now.
Just one stick of butter, like the guy comes in just to buy you a stick of butter.
It's just a single stick of butter at my door.
And then the fees are high, like the Uber fees are higher than the stick of butter.
It's like a ten dollar stick of butter.
But they said, Chad said it'll change your world though.
Actually, oh wait, I lied a little bit.
I do have butter, but it's because I accidentally bought salted butter.
And I haven't been using it.
What's the difference?
What is salted?
You salted?
Salted is fine?
Is it really?
But it's a little saltier.
I don't want salty banana bread.
Sweet and salty?
That'd be okay.
Might be good.
Okay, I'm gonna go try it.
Alright, I'll eat my pizza.
Yeah, a little break, a little break.
Food break, guys.
Food break.
Oh, we were gonna go deliver the bust.
Yeah, the sexy jaw for the sexy lady.
And I'll still have my medicine too.
Hey guys, I'm not looking forward to do Drunk Marble Rivals later.
I literally just need two and a half hours.
That's all I need.
I'm not.
I was really so depressed earlier this morning because I didn't make it.
Oh yeah, for those who don't know, I was drinking soju the entire time.
I was just like sipping out of the soju bottle.
So yeah, I'm just gonna be reminded the last two and a half hours.
I'm just gonna be reminded of what I couldn't get.
At least I'm drinking to forget that pain.
Just do Quickplay.
Quickplay's not fun, though.
Actually, no, I'll be griefing Eternity Games.
Because I was gonna be like, I was gonna play while drunk in Eternity Games.
And all these people are still trying their hardest to make it to Top 500.
And I'll just be like, it's just literally, I will be the fucking make it or break it.
I'm actually gonna be the Elo terrorist.
Okay, maybe I'm too.
Because it's gonna be like...
I want them all to feel the pain.
I'm not making it.
A true joker.
I'm gonna have so many people hate me.
No, I was...
I was an Elo terrorist sometimes.
Because then, like, at one point I got into a Doom queue.
I got into a Doom queue in, like, Austria.
And it got, like, solo queued.
And I was actually an Elo terrorist.
Oh my god.
Um, okay.
No, it went really bad.
I, like, lost, like, five games.
I lost, like, six games in a row.
It was that bad.
No, even more.
Maybe it was more.
It was definitely more.
I lost a lot of games in a row.
I, at one point, I dropped from, like, um, 350 all the way to 120.
And then I got it back the next day.
I, I, I, that was how bad it was.
At one point, like, this week in general.
I don't remember what day it was.
It all blurred together.
Um, and then I got it back the next day.
But, like, it...
It got so bad, I left VC and I muted chat.
Cause I know what, what, I know what mental state I was in.
I knew I was at where I was at mentally.
So I had to leave.
I was like, I don't want them to see me like this.
I don't want them to know.
Oh my god.
And then, like, at one point.
I'm back.
Oh, welcome back.
Welcome back to us.
I also got pizza.
Oh, you got cold pizza too?
Yeah, the one I made last night.
Oh, the really burnt one?
Yep.
Don't you, like...
Isn't that bad for your health?
Don't people say that if you eat, like, burnt food, it raises the likelihood...
Of what?
Of, like...
Getting, like...
Wait, what is it?
Why did she burnt her pizza and she's eating burnt pizza?
Yeah, it's like...
It's not that burnt.
Bro, the picture.
Oh, that's a myth?
Oh my god, my mom lied to me?
Oh my...
Oh, burnt food is a carcinogen.
Did you not know that?
It's not that burnt.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, no, but the picture shows...
How is it any different from when it was normally cooked?
It looks really...
It's crunchy!
What do you mean?
Pizza's not supposed to be that crunchy.
It tastes like a cookie.
Hey, you want some pizza crust, Dad?
I gave him a pizza crust.
Yeah, I don't like crust that much, so he gets scraps.
Why is it crunchy?
Why is it...
It's actually kind of good.
Also, chat, I need to know, like...
How far are we?
Oh yeah, I was wondering that too.
How...
How far are we?
Where are we at?
At this point?
Okay, no, I know, people.
There's no way.
There's no way, like...
There's no way, like, we're 15%.
This feels so much...
I feel like we made up so much progress.
Almost through the tutorial.
20%?
We're only 20%?
I don't have food!
Do they mean of the chapter or of the game?
Oh no, I meant this chapter, guys.
I meant this chapter.
How far are we on?
Guys, I will...
I will progress the game when I know how much left.
Oh, 80%.
Okay, we're so close.
Okay.
Thanks, guys.
Okay, we're at 80%.
So, okay.
Wait, we're not even half...
Okay, guys, now you're...
I think it's just, like, ambience when we're taking too long.
Right?
That's just ambience.
Oh, you want some pizza?
Oh, yeah?
Give me that crunch.
What the fuck is that?
Is that your pizza?
Yeah.
That was like cold pasta.
I'm not gonna waste it.
Okay.
How depressing would it be if I ate cold pasta as well?
Do not eat cold pasta.
No, she made it herself.
She made the pizza herself.
Yeah, it is really crunchy, though.
It is.
That is depression food right there.
What are you depressed about?
I told Chow what I'm depressed about.
What are you depressed about right now?
Oh, what?
You're, uh...
Marvel Rivals.
I almost said Overwatch.
My Marvel Rivals.
Yeah, we're taking a break right now.
I'm depressed about burning my pizza.
Just the little things.
Why are you eating it?
Because I'm not gonna waste it.
It was a whole pizza.
Just give it to your cat.
What?
Do cats eat pizza?
I'd just give it to my dog.
You would feed this to your dog.
Do you love your dog?
You literally said it was alright.
You're like, mmm, it's so good.
I have a funny taste.
Yeah, but your cat's funny, isn't he?
I don't think he would like this.
Isn't he a silly little boy?
Yeah, but like, he's not a stupid little boy.
Wait, I thought like...
Didn't you say one of your cats is like...
Special?
Yeah, he is.
He's inbred.
Yeah, he's inbred.
Yeah.
So like, is he like...
What are you trying to say?
What type of inbred is he?
Is he like...
You know...
He's...
Wait, how is it rude?
Is he like...
What do you mean, what type of inbred?
Like, that's why it's like...
There's different like...
Traits of...
Like when I hear inbred, I just think about the Egyptians.
And like how you know like...
How like...
What was his name?
King Tut?
Was so inbred that like...
What was that expression?
Was it King Tut?
I know there was like that one...
It wasn't the Romanovs.
But it was like one like...
European family.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then like...
One of the kings or whatever only lives...
The...
Habsburg.
Yeah, the Habsburg.
Where he like basically has...
His family was so inbred.
That like he was born...
He was born...
And when he was born, he was born blue apparently.
Because he wasn't breathing or some shit.
And then they brought him back to life or something.
And then like...
Oh, it's Habsburg.
Or Habsburg.
And then like he had like...
The really freaky chin and everything.
And...
It was basically...
Yeah, his family tree was basically like...
A circle.
Yeah, the Egyptians were worse too.
They were so inbred.
I'm gonna look up...
King Tut inbreeding.
Yeah, King Tut's parents were brother and sister.
No way.
Yeah.
How is he the most famous Egyptian king?
Like...
Yeah, I remember King Tut...
I think it's because...
You know, like his...
Sarcophagus.
It's like the one of the most famous ones.
Oh yeah, because it's the one that's like...
Not as damaged or some shit.
So it's like preserved really well.
Yeah, his tomb was preserved.
Yeah, it was preserved really well.
Oh, a fully intact tomb.
Oh yeah, okay, I remember.
Can you imagine like he's the absolute shitty...
Like nobody liked this guy.
And everybody only remembers him.
Because it's...
That's why it was so intact.
No one wanted to rob his tomb.
Was it King Tut that they like...
Got the vocal cord sample of?
And they were like, this is what he might have sound like.
And it was just...
They were like, this is what King Tut might have sound like.
Hold on, I'm gonna send this to you.
Wrong!
Oh, here we go, here we go.
Wait, hold on, let me make sure this is...
Oh, I see that.
Oh, it wasn't him.
Hold on.
Yeah, okay, this is it.
It's so funny.
What is this?
Oh, I'll show you.
I'll link the video.
With a 3D printer!
Yeah!
It allowed them to produce a single sound.
This is so funny.
That's so silly.
Okay.
Why is Team YouTube...
DMing me on Twitter?
What?
Team YouTube?
Oh!
Ms. Boxer!
What is it about?
It says, please take a moment to complete our online survey.
They DMed you on Twitter?
Yeah!
They DMed you on Twitter to complete a survey.
Wait, are you following YouTube's Twitter account?
No!
Wait, that's so weird.
I think they got hacked.
Oh, don't click it.
Wait, they actually got hacked?
I don't know.
Here, I'll show you.
It's 100% them.
This is crazy.
What the hell?
Survey-prod8.sprinklr.com That...
This is sus as hell.
You guys should have said it out loud.
No, that's not the full link, you guys.
Don't worry.
That's not the full link, guys.
It's actually slash index dot html.
Question mark ID.
It seems...
Wait, let me...
I'm gonna ask them, are you hacked?
I'm gonna see if anyone...
I'm gonna look up Team YouTube.
And see if anyone else got the...
That's weird.
Wait, no one else got it?
I'm the chosen one.
Everyone's just complaining about, like, at Team YouTube, my channel, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And then people are just being mad at Team YouTube.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I don't see anything mentioning about...
Mentioning about, like, the DM shit.
Maybe you got...
Maybe you got chosen.
Maybe you should send this link to somebody else and be like, can you take this survey?
I'm gonna put it in your chat.
It's like, oh, what is it called?
You know how, like, people...
Oh my god, that's been so long.
I do, like, those email chains.
I was like, you gotta send this to ten other people.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What are they called again?
Oh my god, it's a chain mail email.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, chain mail, chain mail.
Yeah, chain mail.
You send it to ten other people.
It's like, take this survey.
Or Lucy will come.
Or Lucy's gonna come out and get you.
Guys,
I'm not okay.
I drank up...
I drank more than half a soju bottle right now.
I can feel my face turning...
Like, feeling a little numb.
This is not good.
Should we continue the game?
Give me a sec.
I need to hydrate real quick.
Okay, we gotta take the sexy jaw.
Okay, when was my last auto-save, guys?
I don't remember.
I guess we'll find out.
Probably once we kicked you out.
Where is it?
Where is my little...
My little Lucy?
Little Lucy!
Lucy, where are you?
Where am I?
Lucy goosey.
Wait, is this where she kicked me out?
Oh yeah, it is.
Do you have the jaw?
Oh, you gotta get it from the sink, no?
What is this, a sink?
Oh yeah, it is.
There's the sexy jaw.
Sexy jaw, baby.
Why does it do that?
Oh, was that the guy I saw that just disappeared?
To the basement!
To the floor!
Okay.
Oh wait, that's...
Don't accidentally take your pills.
Okay.
I'm gonna accidentally...
Not the spam again.
I would use your lighter here.
I would too, you're right.
Nah.
Put away the pills.
But I like my pills.
I'm sure your pills like you too very much.
Wait, that's the first time we've seen him.
Like that.
Wait, wait, I think you can go that way.
Oh yeah.
My brain is getting more noticeable.
You might want to take your pills.
Okay!
Hello, madam.
Oh, we got it!
This mannequin wasn't here.
Yes it was, you unobservant fuck!
It was right behind her!
I took the pill.
To the floor.
What's in here?
Oh!
Your lighter?
Oh, I actually took another pill.
Hello?
You're right.
Let me in!
Not now!
Okay, I didn't mean not now.
I was just joking.
I didn't...
He was just listening to you.
He was obliging you.
Okay, sure.
Come right in.
Is that what you wanted?
Wait, where are we?
Where are we?
Okay.
Why is this part lit up?
Okay, it goes up.
Saving is disabled.
Okay, Lucy, that was not fun.
Lucy, when you take daddy's light covers...
Like, what do you want me to do?
Yeah, oh!
Wait, gosh, there's so many...
Wait, where the hell are we?
Are we in the...
What's it called?
The Westenberg house now?
The Westenberg house?
Yeah, we're in the Westenberg house, everybody.
No, no radio.
You've lost your TV privileges.
Yeah, no...
No entertainment for you anymore, Lucy.
Yeah, go to your room!
Go to your room!
You go...
Oh, madam.
I'm not happy right now.
Okay.
She wants me.
What's that?
What does that mean?
Doki, what does that mean?
I don't know.
If I keep going forward, nothing bad will happen to me.
Just keep going.
Yeah, someone said do not stop.
Okay.
You have to find her or...
I do.
Boy.
I think maybe find her, don't find...
The monster, right?
Yeah.
I hear her on the left.
Your other left.
There's too many.
Why are they so hard to open?
It's an easy door!
This is not easy.
Who was that opening...
Opening things is not easy.
Flash?
There?
Here?
No.
Oh, maybe?
Oh wait, this might be the monster.
Peekaboo!
Can I open this?
I'm gonna open everything...
And it's gonna be the last thing I open.
I don't know.
This is not easy.
I still hear her on the left.
Maybe this one.
Is this a death?
Come on!
What?
We have to find her.
Not it.
What sound does she make?
Minus that thing.
Yeah.
What sound does she make?
What if I just open...
Wait, where am I?
Let's open the first one.
So I need to find her.
Yeah.
Not...
Okay.
Anything in here?
I don't...
I think you should use your ears.
No, it's okay.
Okay.
Guys, we'll be here forever.
It's okay.
Okay.
Not that one.
Maybe not that one.
Hold on.
Does she...
She doesn't...
I don't think that one.
She doesn't rumble, right?
I don't know.
This one?
Wait, keep going to your left.
There.
How are you supposed to tell which one is her?
Lucy makes...
Apparently she makes gurgles.
Okay.
At least I found something.
At least she used her ears, guys.
At least...
You know what?
You get this one.
You got this one.
What?
No!
They all gurgle.
I don't know if they all gurgle.
No, they definitely all don't gurgle.
I don't hear anything.
Yeah, because your volume is not up high enough.
No, but there's no gurgling from this door.
No.
Oh my god, that gurgle is so loud.
Lucy's hungry.
That's Lucy's stomach, guys.
Lucy, if you want...
God damn it!
What?
If you want dinner tonight, Lucy, you better come out.
You better come out.
You're not getting dinner.
We're having a favorite.
The peanut butter was so good.
Was it actually?
But have you tried it without it?
Yes!
It's the only time I've tried banana bread without butter.
Yeah, yeah, but...
So you did an experiment to see if butter with banana bread was good?
Yeah, I trusted them.
They all said try.
It's amazing.
And I followed them.
What if I just open like this?
Oops.
Like, you can't get me if I don't look at it.
But you still have to find her.
What?
It's not the Weezy.
I don't think it's the Weezy breathing.
It's the...
Oh my god!
I was like, oh, it's this one.
Don't go to the Weezy.
Don't go to the asthmatic ghost.
Go to the gurgle ghost.
The gurgle ghost.
They all sound the same.
I can't tell.
Some of them are like this.
That's the...
You're clearly the ghost expert.
Let me know which door to open.
No, I said you got this.
No, no, no.
You're literally the ghost expert.
You're the expert on ghosts.
I'm communicating with them.
Someone said we're looking for a doll piece.
Oh.
So maybe...
Does this cabinet speak to you?
Shut up.
I don't think there's anything in there.
I'm double checking.
You don't trust me.
Wait, to the left?
Wait, hold on.
No, not that.
That's the Weezy.
Don't go to the Weezy.
We don't want the Weezy.
We want...
It was back towards the other ones, no?
Are they all randomized?
Or am I just that unlucky and I keep opening the same one?
I don't
know anymore.
No, I just accidentally did the camera.
Sounds like a cat.
Sounds like my cat snoring.
The inbred one?
Yeah, actually.
Sometimes he's so loud I can hear him from the other room.
Is this one?
I don't think so.
Daddy's snoring in here.
Daddy needs his machine.
Daddy's CPAP machine.
Where is it, Lucy?
Daddy needs his CPAP machine.
Where is it?
Oh no.
Maybe.
There's nothing inside.
Is there anything inside?
No.
Is there anything behind that one?
Is there anything behind that gurgly?
I don't think there's just one cabinet.
Yeah, it's just against it.
What?
Take a picture.
Snapshot.
That's going to be my cringe compilation.
I think that one is wheezy though.
I think it'll...
I mean, he is wheezing.
There's a back in front.
Did the other one have a back?
No, it's like against the cabinet.
It's against the wall.
This one sucks.
Yeah.
Try this one.
No, that's the other side.
Try the other side of it.
Oh, I already opened the other side.
Oh, you already opened it.
What?
Is there actually...
Yeah, I can't open it.
It's against the wall.
To the window.
To the wall.
It's against the wall.
Find a hole on the floor?
What?
There's a hole?
No.
Oh, the doll was just an achievement.
What?
What was the point?
Hole on the floor?
There's a ladder.
Where's the ladder?
No way.
Maybe if you should look at the floor.
Oh yeah, sorry.
I forgot.
That's where holes are.
I feel like we would've seen it though.
Oh, it's inside the cabinet.
We should've been looking inside.
Oh, so we're avoiding the gurgles.
The find the hole.
That one seems good.
Not much.
Maybe.
I think this one's fine.
No.
I think there's something here.
But I don't know.
Oh, it's in the back corner of the room?
So like here?
There's so many sounds.
So many sounds.
Can I open this one?
I forgot.
I don't think they close if you open them, so...
No, no, no.
I mean like, but like...
Oh, can you?
Yeah, do you think this has a monster?
I can't tell.
Can't tell.
They're like everywhere.
It's just like, open me.
Definitely not that one.
Open me.
That one's okay.
This one's fine.
Oh, can you quick save here?
Can I?
No.
Here, fuck you up.
Oh, you got the doll!
I did it.
Okay, now we...
That was not what we were looking for, but okay.
I ate the doll.
Can't tell.
I wish we had like a spray paint.
Yeah, I know.
I would be like, no for this one.
No, god damn it!
I did it again!
I was about to say not that one.
Why'd you open it?
I thought it was the same cabinet.
So is the hole inside the...
Yeah, it says inside the cabinet.
When we got into that room, people were like, this is the worst part.
This is the worst part.
I'm gonna look it up, see if there's any tips.
It's on the floor?!
Wait, you guys said it was in the cabinet!
Ladder is not in the wardrobe.
I fucking...
Oh my god.
Can't believe it.
Massage cabinet room.
I'm looking at the floor.
Where could it be?
Someone said as you enter the room, just look to your right and there's a hole in the corner of the map.
Fall into it.
Oh.
Oh, there it is.
Look, there's the hole.
We did it.
Lucy, I'm back.
Oh, what the fuck?
Wait, what was that?
There was like a shadow on the ground.
No, there wasn't.
Yeah, there was.
It was a...
Who was that?
Was that me?
Wait, if we stand there, does it become us?
Oh my god.
I'm him.
You're me.
Oh my god, that means we could've gotten the doll and left.
Oh my god.
It could've...
Wait, try...
Wait, there's gotta be something with him.
Oh, see how it's lifted up there.
Click it, click, click.
Or interact.
Oh yeah, there it is.
Oh, there's another hole.
If there's a hole, there's a goal.
Yeah.
Goodbye.
You must pay the troll toll to get into the boy's hole.
Oh, this doesn't look good.
Oh, it's saving...
Why every time I try to save?
What's the point of the quicksave?
Yeah, how am I supposed to use a quicksave if I can't quicksave?
Ooh, sticking my hand through it, just like Silent Hill.
Yeah, just like Silent Hill.
Yeah.
But at least this time it's not a potty.
What did I get?
What is that?
You're tearing apart the foundation.
Yeah, I was like...
Oh my god, I got a whole fucking stick.
What is that?
What did I get?
That's it?
What is that?
What did I do?
Maybe it moves something on the other side.
Oh.
Unlock the passage?
But how do I get out?
Does it unlock another passage here?
Maybe.
Just check it out.
Oh yeah, I can go back up.
Oh, I can go back up.
Okay.
I'm not locked in.
Okay, saving is still disabled.
Okay, fine.
Wait, try it when you're not on the stairs.
Okay, nevermind.
Oh, it locks something over here, right?
Probably.
That's where I came from.
Or not where I came from, but that's where...
Maybe this room.
Oh, hey, panda.
It's the weed room.
This is daddy's business.
Daddy's secret business.
Wait, I just sit here.
Daddy is breaking bad up in here.
Schedule one daddy.
Schedule one daddy time.
What's in here?
Use your lighter.
Use the lighter.
Oh.
Daddy's sorry.
Daddy didn't mean it.
Daddy quit.
Daddy doesn't do that anymore.
Don't tell mommy.
Daddy stopped cooking.
Try this door.
Oh, I have to go to that room.
No, there was another door right there too though.
Behind you.
Oh, nevermind.
Just kidding.
I didn't realize there was a chair.
What?
It lit up.
Oh, there's a dresser.
I can't see.
Yeah, that's kind of horrible.
Why are you pausing?
I can't see.
Turn the gamma up.
Okay.
Alright.
Daddy needs to see you real quick.
Yeah, it's just too dark.
I still can't see.
Just go forward.
Just go in there.
Why are you turning around?
I can't fucking see.
I can't see.
What do you mean?
Like, what do I look at?
Hello?
No, it won't let me use the lighter.
It says something I won't light up.
Yeah, it did say that.
It did say that.
What about in the...
On the plants?
Light it up, baby.
Do I not go here?
There's gotta be something else in there, no?
All you did was see a panda.
Yeah.
I have to touch the chair again?
Maybe not.
Maybe not, yeah.
Oh, there's another chair?
Oh, the one by the closet, right there.
Oh, this one.
Oh!
Oh, Nemi, thank you for the raid!
Oh, Nemi!
Hey!
Sorry, my gamma's up all the way.
I couldn't see.
I...
No, you don't understand.
It was that one room, guys.
It was for the new...
It was literally that one room.
Hello, Naplings!
Hello!
I cannot store this.
What the fuck do you mean I can't store it?
Put it in my pocket!
Wait.
Yeah, put that away.
Use both hands.
There you go.
Oh, I need to use two hands.
Two hands.
Gotta put it down.
Okay, now...
Oh, oh!
Interact?
Drop?
Oh, there you go.
I figured it out.
Daddy knows what she's doing.
Okay.
Lucy...
You locked me in the closet, Lucy!
That does not make daddy happy.
We are playing as a dad who killed their family.
And we're on the daughter's chapter.
Yeah, we're on Lucy's chapter.
For anybody curious why we keep saying daddy.
I would also be concerned.
Was that a candle?
What did he do?
Why did he throw sand at us?
What the fuck?
What is he doing?
That's daddy's daddy, guys.
Oh no, it's uncle Joe.
It's uncle Joe.
Oh no, he's always been a little bit weird.
Wait, what was that?
I don't know, I'm not looking for it.
Okay.
Ignore uncle.
Ignore daddy's special friend.
Oh no.
Why won't it light up?
I'm in a maze.
Oh gosh, can you save here?
Are you kidding me?
What's the point of quick saving in this game?
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Where is this place?
Where is this hellhole I'm in?
Oh, that's a painting of...
Uncle Joe.
Wait, how am I seeing uncle Joe?
That's uncle Joe's special mask.
Okay.
So this is an actual maze, it seems.
Oh no, I don't do well with mazes.
Well, it's like...
Have I been here before?
That door is open.
Have I been here?
I don't remember, Mint.
I don't know.
Oh, oh, wait.
This looks promising.
Oh, there's a key!
Did you see the door?
There was a locked door.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, where did I go?
I think it was upstairs.
I'm gonna go this way.
Okay, it was upstairs.
Okay.
It was down like a regular hallway, not one of these...
Crusty, dusty hallways.
Maybe that one right there.
Oh, no.
Oh, there's that one.
The only other door.
I couldn't remember.
Another area or not.
Everything looks the same.
Why has this not been renovated?
I think...
Uh-oh.
Does that have a clue?
Uncle Joe?
It won't let me go for it.
Oh.
Are you sure?
Oh, it's Uncle Joe's friends.
What?
That's a person moving.
Wait, can you take out your lighter?
What?
Wait.
How do I get out of here?
Maybe we have to find a plank of wood and put it across.
Wait.
Was I supposed to bring that plank with me this entire time?
No.
Maybe I'll bring this.
Can I bring this?
It works just as well.
Also, why can't we just jump?
Wait.
The plank from before?
No way.
Yeah, you couldn't pick it up, no?
I couldn't.
No way.
Don't do this to me.
Don't do this.
The one standing up?
There's a plank that stands up?
Oh, is this the one with the eyes?
Oh, that one.
Just don't worry.
I think they should...
They should have painted it yellow.
I was going to say...
They need to do the gamer paint.
No, I'm like that wiener dog that tries to carry the stick through.
How do I bring the stick over?
We need gamer paint, everybody.
It's proven to be necessary.
Yeah, the eyes don't work as well.
Yeah.
It's so dark.
They won't even let us use our...
Yeah, lighter.
Our lighter.
Hello,
I'm okay.
I would just go.
I would just keep walking.
Did you see him go into that room?
That was kind of crazy.
Look forward.
Doki bird.
But the camera scares him.
He said the camera scares him.
Let's go to the red room.
Red means scary.
Did I close it?
I don't know how to open doors.
I don't know if you noticed that.
It just happened.
I don't know.
I couldn't open the door properly.
I can't see what's happening!
You can't make it scary when I don't...
Oh, it's an empty...
What's the paintings?
Wait, it changed.
Oh, yeah.
That way.
That way?
Is it not this way?
Did I come from here?
Oh, you're right.
I don't know.
I'm lost.
That way.
Oh,
I thought that was Lucy.
Can't see.
Oh my God, my eyes.
Okay.
I just messed up.
Where am I?
Follow the dust particles.
There's a hole, there's a gold.
Okay, we found somewhere new.
Wait, turn around.
Oh wait, there could be items.
Yeah, see?
I have not been picking those up.
That's fine.
Where am I?
Oh my God, are we hoarders?
This is from Daddy's business.
He collects antiques.
Oh, is it parkour?
I can't move.
Oh wait, no, parkour!
This is Daddy's own parkour area.
Daddy is trading for American Ninja.
Can I be famous, Lucy?
Give me a sec.
I'm learning American Ninja right now.
Let's go!
American Ninja.
This is what they mean when they said...
When I was a kid, I walked uphill everyday to get to school.
This is what they meant by that.
My father created his own little obstacle course.
I'm gonna ruin his ass.
What have you done?
I'm back here.
Oh, we are back here.
This is the basement.
Oh, what's going on?
Oh, it's all scratched up.
Was it like that before?
No, it was not.
All these damn lights.
Piss me off!
I'm so mad.
All these damn light covers.
Where do we go now?
What do we do?
We go back upstairs?
How do I go upstairs?
I don't remember.
Turn to the left.
Here?
No, turn around.
Right, there you go.
What's that sound?
I was taking pills.
Oh, I think it's this one.
Can you save now?
Yeah, check if you can save now.
Oh yeah, I should.
Oh my god, the one moment where I could...
It works!
The feature works!
Wait, I'm going back to the basement.
Oh, she blocked the door.
Okay.
Does anybody know what to do?
Someone said like to the bathroom.
Oh, okay.
Maybe there's another mannequin head.
Like the top.
There's a lighter.
Oh, hey!
Close the door.
That's my private business.
What am I supposed to do in the bathroom?
Did you do that?
No.
Hello?
Sorry, I couldn't go over.
I pushed the cover.
What's the ambiance for?
Hello?
God, they have so much toilet paper.
What are you doing?
I don't know.
Hello?
Who are you...
Who are you talking to?
Hello?
She locked me in.
She did?
Yeah.
You can't leave?
Oh, it's jammed.
Lucy?
Daddy's not happy you locked the bathroom, Lucy.
Just open the door.
Are you stupid?
Oh!
Daddy doesn't want to take a bath.
Is it going to turn red?
Oh, you have...
You can put the hair dryer in it.
Oh my god, our candle is...
Lucy called me stinky.
Lucy?
I'm not stinky.
Look, daddy lost his job.
So, it's been rough.
Daddy built the world's most complicated house.
So, I get really sweaty.
What do we do here?
I'm just waiting.
My lighter is going to go out soon.
She took the light covers.
Like, what the fuck did I do?
You got another lighter, though.
You're going to be okay.
Yeah, I have another one.
She knew that we just went through our American...
Ninja training.
Yeah, my American ninja training.
Yeah.
Check around is what people are saying.
Check around.
Check around what?
She locked me in.
Wait, did the cabinet just open?
No, I opened it.
Camera flush the tap.
Oh, is she going to appear in the tub?
I feel like she's going to come out.
No, I feel like she's just going to come out of the tub and be like...
But this is like the longest build-up ever.
I know, like, what if I just don't look?
Oh!
Flash!
Flash it!
It's afraid of the light.
Oh.
What a peeper.
I know.
They're like, we know you try to not look.
Also, why is there a window in the bathroom?
Yeah, I was about to say, why do we have a window?
Why is it?
Did it make, like, the tiniest window in the fucking bathroom?
Um...
Wait...
She's going to pop out, isn't she?
I'm not giving her that satisfaction.
Look around a little bit more, maybe you'll see another one.
Another guy.
There's only one window.
Uh...
Try...
Oh.
Maybe it's time.
It's time.
No, she has the lights.
She took the light switches, guys.
Yeah, she took all the light switches, so we can't turn on the lights.
Yeah, she's been a bad girl.
Oh, wait!
She forgot one.
Lucy!
Shame.
Poor shame.
I like how...
Wait, did we have our gamma still up, by the way?
Oh, wait, no, it's just like that.
Okay, I was like, why does this look...
Wait, is this the seam?
Oh, it's the seam.
Wait, what's happening?
Hello?
How are we supposed to know to go in here to do all of this?
I don't know, there was no hints whatsoever.
No.
Oh, I'm just gonna wear my clothes and just sit in there.
I'm definitely very depressed right now.
Daddy...
It's not how daddy felt.
They're American ninja.
Let's try it out.
Bath time.
Family bonding time.
We're making our own Oni-sen.
Oni-sen?
Wait, how do you pronounce it?
On-sen?
Oni-sen.
Oni-sen!
Hi, Lucy.
Lucy?
Why does Lucy always look so freaky?
Oni-sen.
Oh.
I thought it was...
Is that Pico?
Pico!
What did she do to Pico?
Did she free him?
Did she let him fly out?
She ate him.
She's never ate a bird before.
We've turned into Bendy and the Ink Machine.
Have you ever played that game?
No, I've never played it.
It's fun.
Bendy and the Ink Machine 2 was not fun though.
It was not as fun.
Not as fun as the first one.
The first one had that novelty.
The second one was so fucked up.
There's like a jump scare ghost that literally...
Her entire mission is to just jump scare you.
You don't know when she'll ever pop up.
Ew!
Oh my god, I hated her.
Speak up, dad.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh...
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Why not just give her pills?
Just be like they're happy needles.
Oh...
It's supposed to be the end of the chapter, no?
We're getting all the lore now.
Yeah, we're learning about Lucy.
Yeah, why she gave us needles.
Yeah, and why her jaw is just ripped open.
I don't think we know that.
Did she go to those home remedy doctors?
Oh no!
Oh...
Oh, that's so sad.
It's not their fault.
She's singing.
That's Bendy and the Ink Machine song.
Huh?
Oh, there's a bathtub.
A bathtub.
Lucy, are you ready to go to the Oni-sen with your dad?
Oni-sen?
Oh, it's blood.
Now it's blood.
Oh, she's gonna definitely...
Yeah, she's gonna come out.
She's gonna be like...
Got you!
Alright, Lucy, come out!
No more playing into me.
I know the skunk got you good.
But come out of the tomato juice.
Wait, we're going in.
Oh my god, we're such a freak.
We got sprayed by a skunk.
Is she gonna come out of...
Oh, she's gonna come out like Grudge.
He's whimpering.
He's gonna turn into...
Into Tomato Doki.
This is the metamorphosis.
The process.
Oh, did I try to...
What the fuck?
What a diaper.
Yes!
This is my origin story.
I dunked myself in tomato juice...
and became one.
Oh no!
Oh?
Oh, I'm Lucy now?
I'm Lucy?
Oh no, Lucy's over there.
I see her.
Is that her?
Yeah, she's over there.
Standing?
I don't think so.
No, that is her.
Oh, it is, you're right.
Why is there blood on that?
Oh my god.
I know the voice said she didn't take her meds.
That's her best friend.
Oh!
She ripped her own jaw?
What?
Oh, Lucy's kind of metal.
Wait, this is pretty hardcore.
Bro!
How does she have the strength to do that though?
Like...
Like, the upper body strength to rip open...
Like, how much does that even...
How much force do you need for that?
Right.
Oh, there's a tape and there's a...
Or not a cassette.
There's a VHS tape in the body.
Yeah.
Pride.
Alright, found a VHS tape.
Oh, cool, I got Lucy's jaw.
Progress item.
Oh, wait, I know what to do with this.
Uh, it disappeared.
That's what you do with it.
We did it!
We made progress!
We did!
That wasn't so bad.
Alright.
I'm not doing the next chapter right now, I can't.
No, I think we're good.
I think I'm okay.
Wait, go into the light.
Avoid standing in the dark.
I need to put the progress item.
No, I think it already went.
It disappeared.
Do I?
Yeah, I wanna see her jaw.
My little memento.
I say as I'm not a serial killer.
I keep a little memento for every...
Oh, it is here, look.
Yeah, not creepy at all.
The virgin Mary looking on.
Is this my little confessional box?
Yeah, it's a confessional.
A miniature confessional?
In my house?
Oh my god, I bought a miniature confession box.
Wait, I'll show you a picture.
Wait, can I?
Wait, what?
I went to this...
I forgot what it's called.
You Americans have something similar.
I have this shop called London Drugs.
And they sell these little...
Small bookshelf items.
And one of them was a tiny-ass confessional booth.
I thought it was so fucking silly.
But the one I bought was...
Faulty, so I had to go back.
Because my chat donated me money to go back.
And buy a functioning confessional box.
Because a working one...
When you press it, it will say...
You are forgiven.
So you confess to it.
And then you'll be like...
You are forgiven.
Desktop confessional.
I'll show you what it looks like.
Oh my god.
What?
You should put a little anime figure in it.
And then you press the bench.
And when you press it, it will light up.
And then you say something to it.
And it will be like, you are forgiven.
Does it record what you say?
No, no.
It's just...
Instead of going to actual church...
You can just confess to your...
Desktop confessional.
So my sins will be forgiven.
You know?
It's just a little convenient way to commit sin.
And be forgiven for it.
And be forgiven on the go.
Yeah, be forgiven on the go.
That's such good marketing.
You know?
You did something wrong and you're like...
Oh man, it's not Sunday yet.
Oh man, it's Monday.
I can't go to church right now.
You just finished jorking it.
And you don't even say anything.
You just press the bench.
You're like...
You saw something.
You jorked it to something that you shouldn't have.
And then you press the bench.
It's like, you are forgiven.
No way.
Alright, for those who haven't...
Newer viewers who are like...
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I'll show you guys a picture.
My...
Some of my Dragoons have already seen it.
Because I showed it before.
This is insane.
This is actually...
Yeah.
So it's...
My miniature desktop confessional.
And it literally is like...
All it does is...
It will say they'll forgive me for my sins.
I have to go back and buy another one.
Because this one doesn't work.
It lights up.
It just doesn't forgive me.
It doesn't...
It just doesn't...
Forgive me.
It's like, tell me your sins.
It doesn't forgive...
Wait, does it not need like...
Does it have one of those things you have to pull out?
No, apparently like...
There's a chance for you to get a faulty one.
So I literally bought a one that didn't work.
And then my chat was like...
Your sins were too heavy to be forgiven.
I was gonna say.
And then I love how it's like...
For ages 14 and up.
So if you're 13, you will never be forgiven.
No, you can't have sins then, I guess.
Oh, maybe you're right.
Sins only start when you're 14.
So you get like a...
You know how like...
Children who murder don't go to actual jail.
They go to juvenile jail.
So like...
And then when they're...
Because they're like older kids.
Maybe they'll grow out of it.
The description is insane.
This mini confessional booth features a light up screen, pressure activated kneeler, and a holy voice.
That prompts you to share your sins before offering a comforting...
You are forgiven.
That's what... I guess I wanted to be comforted.
But it didn't comfort me.
There was no voice.
Wait, what's the...
The actual audacity of saying...
We'll teach you the etiquette of entering the confessional.
When they're selling the most black mirror-esque lighting.
And then this is what it looks like, chat.
You see my screwdriver because I was trying to figure out how to fix it.
But it was already broken.
So you see like...
And then like...
When you go in, you press the bench.
And then in the bench...
Wait, let's see where's the other picture.
In the bench, like...
This lights up.
Like the wind over there lights up basically.
Oh my god.
Who's supposed to be on the other side?
That's god.
That's mini god.
Miniature god.
Miniature priest.
That's pocket god.
Yeah, there's a pocket god in there.
Honestly, the best purchase of my life.
Honestly.
I could see...
I could really see though.
Like some old lady having this.
Unironically.
And it's like, oh heavens.
I got it.
I want one.
It's so good.
You know when god is on his day off.
So you bring out the miniature confessional.
Confess on the go, you know.
That can be like a ritual at the end of every stream.
God is like, alright dragoons.
Let's confess.
And then a holy voice goes, you are forgiven.
Just before I end every stream.
That's my goodbye spiel.
Get up and move around.
Instead of just being like, you are forgiven.
Oh my god.
You know how like...
You know how some priests do like...
Do like church live streams now.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And there's like...
What are they called?
You know like the ones that do like...
Like church on the TV.
And then they are like millionaire priests.
What are they called again?
Yeah, but there's a name for them.
Is it not a church?
Oh, televangelist.
Yeah, televangelist.
Apparently they are now doing stream services.
So like...
So they are like, thank you for the...
Thank you for the super chat.
Miss Grayson.
I'm just thinking like...
How do they thank super chats, you know?
May god be with you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They have like...
They also have like a little sound alert that plays.
Oh yeah, like at the choir.
You are forgiven.
Like a choir being like...
Thank you my children for 1 million subscribers.
Today we got our coveted YouTube play button.
YouTube play button.
Yeah, if it's on Twitch, everyone will just be like...
Praise, praise, praise.
Praise, praise.
Can we get a hallelujah sticker in the chat?
Yeah, yeah.
Can we get some hallelujahs in the chat real quick, guys?
Thank you for the sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Some hallelujahs in the chat.
May god be with you.
No, they're not a sub.
They're a number of month devotee.
Oh, you're right.
Thank you for...
Thank you for being a devotee for five months.
Thank you.
Praise, praise, praise.
Hallelujah, hallelujah.
One dollar equals one redemption.
Hallelujah.
And then just imagine the TTS.
And it would be like...
It would be something like...
How do I send this?
Love, Grandma Jo.
My son, help me send this.
I have a question, father.
Oh my god.
Praise, praise, praise.
Hallelujah, hallelujah.
Someone's like, I don't know who deserves to go to hell more right now.
What do you mean?
We're just coming up with the next stream meta, you know?
We're just coming up with...
I have an excuse, I'm drunk, I don't know.
Well, you're not drunk.
Yes, I am.
I finished almost an entire bottle of soju.
You're still coherent.
That's true, I am.
I'm still coherent.
I feel like if I downed the whole thing, it would have been over.
I also like peed too, so...
I like peed out some of it out of my system.
You sprayed the alcohol away.
Yeah.
I balance it with water too, so I don't get like...
If I really want to get fucked up, I just don't drink water.
But that's not a good idea to do on stream.
Because...
I don't know what I'm going to say on stream.
I might go full drunk on drunk.
But I am drunk, though.
I am drunk, I'm just not...
Wasted.
I'm not wasted.
Okay.
You seem the same.
Are you usually like...
What kind of drunk are you?
I'm like...
I don't...
I remember in university...
You know how the legal drinking age...
In the US is like...
21, right?
Yeah, 21.
But in Canada, it's like 18.
So like...
Or 19, I don't remember.
I think it's 18, right?
I don't remember.
I know I'm Canadian, but like...
I like how people are like...
21!
Yeah, no, America's drinking age is 21.
I know like in some...
Some provinces it's 18 and others are 19.
But like...
I had to go to New York.
For something for university.
And then like...
The thing is, obviously, I'm like...
Not 21 at that time.
Right.
So we had to get like the upperclassmen...
To like buy us alcohol and stuff.
And then like...
I haven't got drunk before.
I haven't drank before or anything.
So like, our teacher chaperone...
Bought us wine.
She bought us wine at first.
Wine is fine.
But then like, I took like...
Two sips and then they were like...
You're red, Doki.
And they're like, no more for you.
No, really?
They took the cup away.
And then later on, there was a party.
For the students.
From all other schools to get in New York.
So there was a party.
And then like...
My classmates, they made me my very first drink.
Which was a screwdriver.
And then when I...
Obviously, I didn't know how to drink.
Because it was the first time I ever drank.
And got drunk.
And then they were like...
They were like...
You're more funny when you're drunk.
Here, have some more.
I'll make you more.
And then like...
I had a meeting with somebody.
Outside of the hotel room.
So I had to go meet up with them.
For an assignment.
And then I was walking around.
With my screwdriver.
Out in the open.
Because apparently, that's a crime.
In America.
To walk around with alcohol.
Like, just...
Yeah, I have something to say.
Yeah.
You are forgiven.
And then, like, my friends were like...
What the fuck were you doing?
You could actually...
You could actually get arrested.
For like...
For holding out.
I just realized.
People put paper bags on the alcohol.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because you're not supposed to walk around.
I've never thought about that.
Because I think of Japan.
Where you can walk with...
Open...
Containers.
Yeah, but apparently in America.
You cannot do that.
Yeah, the brown paper bag.
You can't drink out in public.
And it has to be in a brown paper bag if it is.
But you're not supposed to show...
You can't have alcohol in public and stuff.
But yeah, apparently I'm just like...
I'm just like more talkative.
And more funny or something.
Because you're like, oh my god, Doki.
You need to drink more.
They just kept making me screwdrivers.
Did you throw up?
No, no.
I don't know why.
I think I read up on it.
You know, like researched my way about drinking.
I've always like...
Balanced it with water.
But I've never thrown up before while drinking.
I've never got a hangover.
And I've never like...
Thrown up before.
Well...
There's too much for everything.
Drink, drink, drink.
Live on stream.
Drink, drink.
Wait, did you throw up on stream?
I've thrown up on stream.
Wait, multiple times?
I like how you had to think about it.
I was like, did I?
I throw up easily sometimes.
I've never done that before.
I think like, I remember.
It was like...
I almost did.
And I think it was the same reason you did.
It was the...
What was it?
The switch.
The exercise game on the switch.
Oh, yeah!
I ate before as well.
I almost...
I almost did.
I remember it hit you, right?
Ring Fit.
I was like...
I waited two hours.
I was like, that's enough time to digest, right?
It was not.
Two hours is not enough time for your stomach to digest food.
I learned that the hard way.
No, it was not.
I waited two hours and I was not okay.
I was not okay.
Okay, Doki.
I'm gonna leave you now to sober up with your chat.
Alright, alright, alright.
I got some stuff to do.
Oh, yeah.
You're super busy.
I know that.
Yeah.
You guys don't know.
We'll do the other chapters too.
Yeah, yeah.
Next week, right?
Yeah, next week.
We can do next week.
Alright, we'll do it next week, guys.
We'll do chapter 2 next week.
Alright, thanks, Mint.
Thanks for joining me.
Yeah, thanks, everybody.
Say bye-bye to Mint, guys.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, Mint Kitty.
We'll take her out to the back of the farm.
Where she'll get lots of nice treats.
Right, guys?
Have you ever been to the back of the farm?
Mint Kitty?
I'm going now.
Yeah.
Yeah, bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
Okay, that was fun.
Okay, that was not fun.
It was a horror game, guys.
Huge thank you to Mint for coming here to, like, to, like, keep me company and help me with the puzzles.
I think this game would have taken a lot longer if Mint wasn't here to guide me through everything because I was so fucking scared.
But misery loves company, as you guys know.
But, yeah!
I do hope you guys enjoyed today's stream.
I am going to be doing a 2.5 Marvel Rivals stream on Twitch to finish up my quota because I have 2.5 hours left, apparently.
I was like, hey!
I was to the staff.
I was like, how many hours left?
And they were like, 2.5 hours.
I was like, fuck!
I thought I finished it.
So the pain never ends.
The pain...
never ends.
I might just do a quick...
Oh my god.
Wait, I didn't even know she has that expression.
I didn't even know that.
But, um...
What was I saying?
I'm not gonna do rank because, like, um, because, you know, I'm pretty sure there's some people that are still trying to get top 500 right now.
And it would be really fucked up if I...
I am the deciding... I am the deciding teammate in their games on whether or not they get there.
I am the death sentence.
No, I've... I've terrorized enough players the last week already.
So, like, I...
I've terrorized enough people in the last week.
So, I will spare them.
I got... Oh my god, I got yelled at by some fucking one of me pros.
And then, um, they were like, who are you?
You are... And then I looked them up, and oh my god, I am friends with their boss.
So...
I was like, I could literally message their boss right now and, like, just send them the screenshots.
And, like, a fucking clip of, like, their fucking garbage human behavior.
And then they're like, um, they're like, you are fucking terrible.
You're random.
You're fucking random.
You're a nobody or some shit.
And I was just like, lol, look me up.
And then he was like, who is this fucking anime PNG?
Like, you think that's so... And then I looked up his stream.
I was like, you think that's so tough?
And then I'm like, oh, you clearly didn't look up fully who I am.
Like, I'm literally friends with your boss.
Like, I'm just, like, thinking, like, I am literally friends with your fucking boss, you loser.
Like...
And he was mad.
Okay, it was today.
He was mad because I didn't Luna ult.
But the thing is, it's because our Loki copied me.
Our Loki copied me.
And, um, he didn't use his Luna ult.
I was waiting for him.
I was waiting for him to ult so I wouldn't double support ult.
And then he copied me and died.
And then we died together because he didn't ult.
And then the end- and then my- and then the two fucking losers blamed me for the game because I didn't ult.
And I was just like, bro, fuck off.
You guys are, like, I'm gonna amount to nothing.
Like...
Um, it's barely a career.
But yes, no, I I'm petty.
I'm so petty right now.
But I won't do- that's why I wasn't gonna do that.
Um...
Um, because they thought they were, like, big shots.
Because they're like, oh, I'm somebody.
And I'm like, you're barely an- you're barely anybody.
Like...
laughing laughing So that's why I'm not playing rank.
I am not playing rank.
Um, while drunk.
Because I don't wanna- I don't wanna either terrorize.
I don't- laughing I don't know what I'll say when I'm not sober.
Because I might say my inside thoughts out loud.
Um, to those fuck- to people who fuck with me.
Because I- I hold it in a lot.
laughing I- I almost, like, I think if I was drunk and they did that I would have messaged their boss.
I would have messaged their- laughing And then the chat was like, oh, fuck fucking vtubers.
This makes me hate vtubers more.
And I was like, oh my god.
I was just like you are watching a garbage piece of shit.
Like laughing laughing Like, oh yeah, support the guy that harasses other people.
Yeah, you're better than me.
laughing laughing So that is why I am not doing rank.
My- these are my inside thoughts.
I would actually say that to them in voice chat if I play rank.
If anybody pisses me off my inside thoughts will not be my inside thoughts.
laughing
Um, but yeah.
Uh, that- that but yeah, no.
I'm happy I did this stream right after my depression grind because, like, I definitely needed it.
I was very sad.
I was very sad before I took my nap.
Because you know how much time I've like, invested in doing that grind.
So I was like really sad about it.
Um, but like, I feel- definitely feel a lot better now.
Um, it was really fun hanging out with Min throughout it.
And like, it definitely cheered me up a lot more.
I don't know if the drink- the drinking definitely helped.
Um I now know why people are- Okay, this is a joke.
This is a joke.
I know now why people are alcoholics because like, I was sad but now I'm not sad.
But I won't make it a habit.
I won't make it.
I won't make it a habit.
Um, but I definitely feel a lot better.
Yeah, Minkitty?
I don't know what she's doing.
Crazy thing.
And this is a one-time thing.
This is a one-time thing, guys.
I swear to God.
Um, but it definitely cheered me up a lot more because I was actually so depressed.
I was like I was like, doom-posting to my friends.
I was like, okay.
Okay, I'll read you what- okay, I'll read you some of the shit I said I doom-posted.
Such a doomer.
Holy fuck.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Um, I don't know.
I feel like I gained nothing from the whole session the last month and a half, and instead a lot of problems and a lot of wasted time.
Ah, my friend.
I was so- I was dooming so hard before I, like, took a nap.
But to be fair, I played 40 plus hours of Rivals Rank at that time.
And it was more um, all these people who I thought were worse than me are higher ranked.
But I'm okay now.
I'm okay.
I was doom-posting the last, like, three days because like, every time it was a bad session, or like, the last week, because every time every time it was a bad session I was dooming so hard.
But I'm okay now.
Definitely the stream helped a lot.
I had a lot of fun with it.
I had a lot of fun with you guys watching too.
I'm normal now.
Don't worry, I'm normal now.
I didn't wish for just the amount of time I spent on it, but, like, it's alright.
Next season, I am taking a break- like, not break, but, like, I will be doing these- I'm not gonna commit to rank anymore.
I won't be trying for Top 500 anymore.
If it happens, it happens.
But it's not, like, my priority, and I'm gonna be focusing on other stuff now.
Focusing back on, like, you know, my career, my VTubing stuff instead of offline rank grind session, because that was a problem.
That was- that was a huge problem.
But I'm better now.
I'm better now.
I've accepted it.
But yes, everybody, I hope you guys had a great time with me and Mint.
I hope you guys had a fun time hanging out with us.
I am not sober, and I might continue drinking to finish the two and a half hours.
And most likely, I'll- the stream will be, like, in an hour or an half, because I wanna microwave my cold pasta, so I could, you know, get some more food in my system.
But yes, I hope you guys all had a great time.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Oh, Mint was right.
You are forgiven!